alors nous accueillons à présent madame
guanal Nouri présidente de la Fédération
française des sports de glace depuis
juin 2022 et Madame Nathalie péchala
ancienne présidente de la Fédération
française des sports de glace de 2020 à
2022 mesdames je vous souhaite la
bienvenue et vous remercie de votre
disponibilité pour répondre à nos
questions nous avons entamé les travaux
de cette commission d'enquête sur
l'identification des défaillances de
fonctionnement au sein des fédérations
françaises de sport du monde sportif et
des organismes de gouvernance du monde
sportif le juillet dernier l'Assemblée
nationale a décédé de sa création à la
suite de très nombreuses révélations
publiques de sportives et sportifs et de
diverses affaires judiciaires ayant tré
à la gestion de certaines fédérations
nos travaux portent sur trois axes les
violences physiques sexuelles ou
psychologiques dans le sport les
discriminations sexuelles et raciales et
les problématiques liées à la
gouvernance financière des organismes de
gouvernance du monde sportif la gestion
de l'ancien président monsieur gayage a
été abondamment critiqué l'igesr dans un
rapport récent a relevé des manquements
graves pouvez-vous revenir sur les
constats que vous avez pu faire sur la
gouvernance et la gestion de la
Fédération lorsque vous avez pris vos
fonction comment la gouvernance de la
Fédération a-t-elle évolué depuis son
départ quels sont les faits dont vous
avez eu connaissance dans le champ qui
intéresse notre commission et la manière
dont la Fédération y a répondu quel
changement chacune d'entre vous a-t-elle
impulsé dans les domaines qui intéresse
notre commission le cadre existant pour
prévenir détecter signaler et
sanctionner les viol
notamment sexuelle et sexiste le racisme
et les discriminations et les atteintes
à la probité vous paraît-il adapté cette
audition est ouverte à la presse et
retransmise en direct sur le site de
l'Assemblée nationale avant de vous
laisser la parole et d'entamer nos
échanges je vous rappelle que l'article
6 de l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires impose au
personne entendue par une commission
d'enquête de prêter serment de dire la
vérité toute la vérité rien que la
vérité je vous je vous invite donc à
lever la main droite et à et à dire
chacune à votre tour je le jure après
avoir activé votre
micro je le
jure je
jure alors je vous laisse la parole pour
environ 10 minutes pour des propos
liminires toutes les deux puis ensuite
on entamera un échange par question donc
je ne sais pas qui souhaite
commencer mais écoutez je veux bien
prendre la parole en
premier
madame messieurs les parlementaires
madame la
Présidente merci de me donner l'occasion
de m'exprimer au nom de la Fédération
française des sports de glace j'ai
effectivement été élu en juin 2022 avec
l'ambition de donner un nouvel élan à
cette fédération et répondre aux
attentes des clubs qui souhaitent une
fédération plus proche de leurs
préoccupation ceci tout en poursuivant
la démarche de transformation
tant sur les questions éthiques que sur
les
violences j'ai par ailleurs après une
phase de diagnostic largement éclairé
par l'enquête de
l'igsr souhaitaz m'emparler des
questions d'organisation de la
gouvernance et des questions financière
dans une perspective de bonne
gestion je vous ne cache pas que rien ne
m'a été épargné par ces chantiers
colossaux mais grâce à une belle équipe
que j'ai souhaité faire correspondre à
mon image et à mon à mes valeurs surtout
nous avançons et les résultats se
mesurent sur le terrain chaque
jour j'ai une certaine sérénité qui est
obtenue et les témoignages par
l'ensemble des
acteurs les retours les plus
satisfaisants restent ce nos sportifs
bien entendu qui expriment le fait de se
sentir en sécurité respecté et le le
beau résultats sont peut-être
l'illustration de ce bien
retrouverver mais je ne veux pas faire
d'angélisme car ce n'est jamais acquis
et notre engagement doit rester entier
et j'ai conscience que nous devons
maintenir un haut degré de
vigilance cet espoir ne doit en effet
pas cacher les craintes exprimées de
toutes celles et ceux qui ont subi des
traumatisme marquant et notre travail
est de leur prouver que cette
transformation justement n'est pas
éphémère
mais que nous ne reviendrons plus en
arrière l'année passée fut riche et
tourmenté une fédération avec beaucoup
de vid tant sur le plan du personnel
fédéral que technique des événements
assuré avec des échéances très courtes
et des financements à
trouvés puis arrive la la décision
pardon de Madame la Ministre de
diligenter donc cette inspection
générale les conclusion de l'inspection
m'ont conforté dans cette
analyse ce fut-elle un audit à 360 pour
moi en un temps
record je tiens d'ailleurs à saluer ce
travail méthodique et minutieux qui a
confirmé mes doutes et interrogation
mais surtout qui m'a évité toute marque
de complicité avec ce
passé je tenais et je tiens à être
fidèle à mes valeurs et celle du sport
tout en privilégiant évidemment
l'intérêt
fédéral puis vient une phase de
turbulence un bureau exécutif divisé
paralysé j'ai dû marquer une réelle
rupture pression chantage menace
effraxon de mon bureau lettres anonym
attaque personnel campagne de
diffamation humiliation intimidation vol
de données tout était
permis heureusement nous faisons preuve
d'un un ité de force avec mon DTN
monsieur Jamel cheek qui est ici présent
et ma secrétaire générale madame
Stéphanie Daval également en fond de
salle que je
remercie et qui partage avec moi cet
intérêt fédéral avec la volonté et
l'ambition de faire briller notre
fédération il a leur fallu rassurer
fédérer dialoguer rassembler et
expliquer nous avons affronté la
défiance de certains refusant ces
changements concernant nos actions nous
avons commencé par revoir nos process
différents contrôles contrats factures
et des consultations avec des appels
d'offre puis la refondte des textes
fédéraux via une commission dédiée et
mise en place conformément à la loi de
mars
2022 cette commission a travaillé sur la
mise à jour des statuts le règlement
intérieur financier disciplinaire le
règlement éthique également on
envisageit la création d'une commission
des agent sportif et préparer un
règlement avec une convention
d'hébergement des sportifs notamment
ainsi avec le soutien des autorités de
tutelle nos nouveaux statuts règlement
intérieurs sont prêts et seront
d'ailleurs votés prochainement lors de
la l'assemblée générale prévue fin
novembre j'ai souhaité aussi que mon DTN
occupe désormais ses fonctions en
conformité avec ses
attributions je m'attache à
veiller et à travailler en lien constant
Ave avec la DTN une relation en totale
confiance qui s'est instaurée et je
pense que c'est la clé de notre
réussite nous avons engagé de nombreuses
actions notamment sur la formation
continue des entraîneurs des dirigeants
de groupement également et j'ajoute
également que la confiance elle est
retrouvée avec l'ensemble des
partenaires institutionnels je pense à
la ns évidemment le CNOSF la direction
des sports le ministère signal sport et
je souligne que madame la ministre et
son administration se montre attentif et
vra vraiment aidant dans ma démarche de
transformation j'ai ainsi pu mettre en
œuvre des changements importants par
exemple nous avons mis en place des
procédures de mise en concurrence
lorsque cela se justifiait et que la
ressource n'existait pas en interne dans
le respect de notre règlement financier
évidemment qui donne déjà un cadre mais
que nous allons faire
évoluer je mets
fin à la logique d'appel à des
entreprises extérieures lorsque les
prestations sont réalisables en interne
ces prestataires ont représenté des
coûts colossaux et été installés sans
remise en question j'ai donc procédé à
des recrutements pour la communication
interne et externe par exemple
l'événementiel un poste très important
et la direction des opérations les
effets sont immédiats sur l'économie
générale de la Fédération et sur
l'efficacité de la conduite des
dossiers
j'ai voulu ouvrir les bras à toutes les
bonnes volontés j'ai notamment ouvert la
porte à certains
champions comme sua Bonali Philippe
candellorou Sarah bitball qui reviennent
à la Fédération avec
enthousiasme et avec qui nous avons
entamé des collaborations
prometteuses le DTN est toujours en
phase de recrutement de son équipe avec
le soutien de la direction des sports
bien sûr et la ns il a redonné confiance
à des cadres et insuffle un nouvel élan
dans un bel esprit
d'équipe au-dessus de toute
considération partisane j'ai ouvert la
porte et
elle le reste elle le reste pour toutes
les énergies qui souhaitent s'investir
sincèrement dans le sport pour une
transformation durable et cette belle
fédération à laquelle nous sommes
attachés en revanche je n'accepterai pas
de retour vers les pratiques du passé je
veux désormais aller de l'avant nos
sportives et sportifs quel que soit leur
niveau méritent cet engagement sans
faille je tiens à assurer également une
communication accrue et en toute
transparence cela se traduit par exemple
par des bureaux exécutifs et des
conseils fédéraux plus réguliers au
cours desquels je rends compte de mes
actions mais également par une
communication digitalisée directement
avec mes clubs qui contribuent à assurer
la proximité à laquelle je tiens je
réalise beaucoup de dé placacement sur
tout le territoire pour aller à la
rencontre des bénévoles dirigeants
entraîneurs officiels et licenciés qui
sont tous à
écouter
enfin je ne peux ne pas vous parler de
la lutte contre les
violences tout d'abord j'aimerais
revenir sur l'action saillè en
collaboration avec colosse au pied
d'argile engagé par Nathalie péchala ici
présente il s'agit d'un projet européen
de protection des jeunes patineurs
bénéficiant d'un soutien du programme
Erasmus plus de colosse au pied d'argile
évidemment de l'Université de Lyon et en
lien avec la féd internationale de
patinage la Hongrie et les Pays-Bas je
salue également l'investissement de nos
deux référent intégrité de l'élu
référent LVS et de notre
rapporteur dès le début de mandat il y a
eu refonte du règlement éthique et
disciplinaire et la mise en place de la
déclaration des intérêt
particulier nous étions une des
premières fédérations à le faire avec
l'aide du CNOSF et la direction des
sports enfin le projet novateur sur
lequel nous travaillons dur en ce moment
c'est ce projet Sentinel il s'agit en
fait d'identifier dans chaque club et
ligue un référent lutte contre les
violences qui sera formé accompagné dans
le temps par la Fédération et qui
participera lui-même à former les
pratiquants qui fera du recueil de
parole évidemment le lien avec les
associations idouines et les référents
intégrité il s'agira à mon sens un outil
précieux de
prévention nous travaillons d'ailleurs
dans ce sens évidemment avec colosse au
pied d'argile mais aussi la voix de
Sarah second souffle et d'autres
encore mais tout ceci ne fonctionneraiit
pas si les sujets n'étaient pas en
permanence au cœur de nos actions
quotidiennes
nous considérons qu'elles le seront
durablement car le risque dans le monde
du sport est permanent et ceci est lié à
notre environnement nous le savons et
nous sommes parfaitement lucides nous
avons décidé d'agir en prévention de
manière récurrente avec des
sensibilisation obligatoire de nos clubs
pour l'obtention par exemple du label
école française de glace de traquer les
prédateurs de les débusquer de les punir
et de montrer dans chaque prise de
parole notre détermination et notre
fermeté notre projet Sentinel s'inscrit
pleinement dans cette ambition de
protéger nos licenciés et toute forme de
violence
l'omerta institutionnalisé est terminé
et nous avons fait de gros progrès sur
la libération de la parole grâce aux
actions de nos référents intégrité
celles des associations comme colosse au
pied d'argile et la voix de
Sarah nos organes disciplinaires se
renforcent également pour que le temps
de la décision soit efficace et
contribue à rendre crédibles nos
actions le rôle des services déconcentré
de l'État évidemment est fondamental
dans le cadre des enquêtes conduites les
fédérations doivent prendre leurs
responsabilité et je me suis engagé pour
cela elles doivent être soutenu pour
réussir ces transformations et
neutraliser les mauvaises pratiques nous
devons tous être
vigilants je crois que je peux
aujourd'hui qu'après toute ces
turbulence dire que nous avons apporté
avec mon équipe la sérénité attendue par
toute la communauté fédérale et nos
club une peur du retour d'anciennes
pratique est largement exprimée mais je
crois que le sentiment disparaît au
profit d'une confiance qui s'installe
peu à peu au gris des rencontres que
nous
multiplions il fallait instaurer cette
confiance donner de vrais signe de
transformation et c'est ce qui est
désormais
engagé le rapport d'inspection générale
et ses préconisations nous sont utiles
chaque jour
et nous ont largement guidé durant ces 5
derniers mois depuis la réception du
rapport les 34 recommandations ont tout
été suivies et certaines sont même
abouties j'ai conscience que nous devons
évidemment faire preuve d'humilité sur
ces questions mais notre détermination
est entière et je crois que ce qui va
faire réellement notre réussite c'est la
créativité incroyable de notre équipe et
notre refus total du
renoncement je vous remercie de votre
attention et de la possibilité de cette
présentation alors par contre il va
falloir juste éteindre votre micro pour
que Madame péchala
puisse bonjour madame la rapporteur
bonjour à
tous alors j'ai été convoquée au titre
d'ancienne présidente de la Fédération
française des sport de glace mais je
suis aussi une ancienne sportive de
niveau dans sur glace donc une des
disciplines du patinage
artistique j'ai commencé à l'âge de 7
ans j'ai fini à 30 ans pendant ces 23
années j'ai vu j'ai vécu des violences
morales physiques sexuelles la
corruption et le
dopage ça c'est la partie ombragée du
sport du haut niveau et à chaque fois je
me suis senti impuissante il y a une
partie lumineuse
heureusement j'ai vécu ma passion j'ai
vécu de ma passion j'ai pu faire des
études décrocher un diplôme en école
supérieure de commerce vivre en Russie
aux États-Unis faire des belles
rencontres et décrocher quelques
médailles notamment de titres de
champion d'Europe et deux médailles de
bronge au championnat du monde trois
participations aux Jeux olympiques en
2006 2010 et 2014 et en ça je me
considère comme chanceuse chanceuse
parce que je j'ai pu mener à bien mon
projet définir des objectifs à court
terme sélectionner les experts aller
chercher des financements privés prendre
les décisions et les assumer je me suis
constru dans
l'adversité de la Fédération française
des sports de glace je n'en attendais
rien si ce n'est des sélections
internationale la première fois qu'ils
sont venus nous voir pour nous demander
ce dont on avait besoin on était déjà
champion d'OPE Europe c'est tellement
facile d'aller applaudir quelqu'un qui
est déjà tout en haut et de lui dérouler
le Tapier
rouge en 2014 j'ai mis fin ma carrière
de sportif de niveau et je suis devenue
consultante dans les médias
conférencière et coach notamment pour la
Fédération Française et sport de glace
lors des regroupements équipe de France
novice et et junior dans sur
glace et quelques années avant de
raccrocher euh la compétition euh j'ai
voulu m'engager dans les instances
non pas pour rendre ce que le sport
m'avait
apporté parce que tout ce que j'ai gagné
tout ce que j'ai eu je suis allé
chercher à la sœur de mon front avec
l'aide évidemment de mon partenaire et
de toute l'équipe proche de nous les
entraîneurs les chorégraphes les
préparateurs
mentaux et physique h moi ce que je
voulais c'était construire un avenir
meilleur pour les générations
euh d'aujourd'hui et de demain et je
suis pas un bisounours je sais que ça
nécessite énormément de travail et la
première des choses c'est encore
d'ouvrir les yeux de se rendre compte de
ce qui se passe véritablement sur le
terrain
donc aux alentours 2010 ou 2012
peut-être je suis rentrée à la
commission des athlètes de haut niveau
du CNOSF donc du Comité national
olympique et sportif
français puis quelques années après au
comité technique de la Fédération
internationale de patinage en 2017 j'ai
demandé à rencontrer Sébastien Boel qui
est donc le fondateur et le
directeur de colosse au pied d'argile et
je suis devenue ambassade
h et j'ai pris la parole sur le sujet
des violences sexuelles lors de la
commission des athlètes d' ha niveau
donc du Comité national olympique à peu
près vers 2017 c'est-à-dire quelques
années après les hashtag meou et les
premières prises de parole dans le
milieu artistique notamment aux
États-Unis on était un peu plus de 20
autour de la table donc de disciplines
complètement différentes et quand je
leur ai dit que statistiquement autour
de la table il y en avait au moins
quatre ou cinq qui avaient subi ce genre
de violence tout le monde a baissé la
tête et à l'issue de de cette de cette
réunion on s'est retrouvé un petit
groupe de femmes quatre ou CIN et on
s'est on avait toutes des choses à se
dire en 2019 on a pris la parole dans
une tribune d'ailleurs pour dénoncer les
violences sexuelles dans le milieu
sportif et puis en 2020 quand le
scandale les violences sexuell a
éclaboussé très largement le monde des
sports de glace via le livre de Sarah
beitball did gaeg donc mon prédécesseur
a mississionn et je me disais à ce
moment-là que pour faire changer un
système il fallait en faire partie donc
j'ai décidé de proposer ma candidature
et en arrivant donc à mi mandat je me
suis retrouvée avec des élus qui étaient
déjà en cours de mandat il y en avait
certains qui avaient démissionné pareil
pour les salariés certains étaient parti
il y a pas eu d'autres démission quand
je suis arrivée et j'ai trouvé une
équipe cœur qui qui était intègre en
très grande majorité qui était précieuse
puisqu'il n'y avait pas d'archive au
sein de la Fédération française des
sports de glace et les grandes enant
information enfin les informations
importantes étaient detenues simplement
par un noyau dur qui n'était plus
présent fort heureusement à la
Fédération voilà donc cette cette équipe
a pu me donner l'historique de ce qui
s'était passé les dernières années en
tout cas ce que monsieur gayag a bien
voulu leur transmettre
oralement 3 jours après les élections il
y a eu cette crise sanitaire et le
Lockdown
h donc çaen est suivi une crise
économique il a fallu aller chercher des
financements et continu
nos actions de développement et de
performance avec les Jeux Olympiques H
qui est aurait lieu 2 ans après et les
championnat du monde à organisé à
domicile et nous n'externalisons pas
nous n'externalisons pas
pardon les grands événements et
d'ailleurs les petits événements
nationaux également sur notre
territoire mais ma priorité ça a été le
sujet de
l'éthique la lutte contre les violences
sexuelles la lutte contre tous les types
de violence d'ailleurs mais surtout les
éque au niveau des choix des décisions
prises qu'il soient tous ces choix
justifiés et
justifiables on est devenu une
fédération exemplaire sur la lutte
contre les violences sexuelles
évidemment je pourrais vous faire un
détail plus précis des actions qu'on a
mené sur le
terrain on a fait on a changé les
statuts et je crois qu'on a été la
première fédération à à voter la
limitation de
mandat il y a eu
deuxinpection générale qui ont été lancé
en 2020 l'une sur les violences
sexuelles dont je n'ai jamais le le
retour
puisque ce qu'on m'a dit c'est que ça
concernait mon prédécesseur et donc
c'est lui qui qui en a été destinataire
et la deuxième sur tout ce qui était
gestion administrative et et financière
j'ai vu les équipes des inspecteurs par
deux fois la Fédération ils m'ont
auditionné ils ont aussi auditionné
d'autres membres d'autres
élus l'automne 2020 et l'automne 2021 et
à chaque fois on leur a remis une liste
enfin des documents conséquents euh tout
ce qui était demandé donc sur leur liste
je me suis étonné de ne jamais avoir ces
conclusions de de de cette inspection
qui avait été lancée avant même mon
arrivée c'està-dire avant mars 2020 j'ai
relancé plusieurs fois oralement et par
écrit le ministère en leur disant que la
menace de gayage qu'il revienneent
n'était pas complètement éloigné et
qu'il nous fallait absolument ses
conclusions ça n'a pas été le cas c'est
Madame la Ministre Amélie oua casterra
qui l'a
relancé en
2022 et là l'équipe a changé l'équipe
des inspecteurs a
changé donc j'ai découvert l'envers du
décor à la Fédération Française sport de
glace et j'insiste sur le fait
que ça ne concerne pas tous les
présidents fort heureusement des clubs
qui constituent les sports de glace ça
ne concerne pas tous les présidents qui
constituent le monde des sports de glace
évidemment mais j'ai découvert le
clanisme les intérêts personnels et les
petits arrangements entre amis les
lettres être anonyme aussi envoyer
régulièrement aux élus dont évidemment
je faisais partie qui allait pour ma
part en tout cas jusqu'à menacer mes
deux filles donc croyez-mi ce mandat
enfin ce demi-mandat ça a été un défi
permanent sur tous les
plans 2 ans et 3 mois après mon élection
à la Fédération française des sport de
glace l'ancien monde a repris ses droits
did gayage a trouvé son cheval de tro B
la personne de Quanelle nourrit il a
fait sa campagne il a écrit sa
profession de FO de foi et il a mené les
tractations et je suis très à l'aise
pour vous le dire puisque c'est dans le
rapport de l'inspecction générale et que
toutes les preuves y sont je pense que
Didier gaygé n'a pas supporté que la
Fédération française des sports de glace
puisse fonctionner sans lui après 20 ans
de
gouvernance en 2021 je suis rentrée au
conseil d'administration du
CNOSF et là je voudrais juste ne pas
faire de raccourci ni d'amalgame j'ai
découvert au sein des membres du CNOSF
donc du Comité national olympique et
sportif français des personnes
valeureuses et intègres moi là je vous
raconte simplement mon histoire
personnelle on a voulu proposer avec
quelques présidents en jeune président
pas par l'âge mais par le niveau
d'expérience un rapport d'étonnement qui
portait sur la gouvernance le management
l'événementiel et le fonctionnement avec
les autres instances sportives
nationales mais malheureusement ça n'a
pas pu être re mené parce que le temps
n'est pas extensible et il s'est passé
aussi beaucoup de choses au niveau du
Comité national olympique depuis fin
2022 voilà je vous donne juste cette
ligne là si vous voulez plus
d'information je serai même de vous en
donner aujourd'hui pour le Comité
national olympique je porte le dossier
du Club France donc qui sera l'épicentre
du mouvement sportif français pendant
les Jeux Olympiques et paralympique de
Paris 2024 mais moi je m'occupe
simplement de la partie olympique et je
suis présidente de l'association promier
de cordé donc qui apporte le sport dans
les services pédiatriques des hôpitaux
voilà merci à à toutes les deux pour ces
propos liminires donc j'ai plusieurs
questions euh entre bah du coup pour
toutes les deux
euh
euh d'abord je vais commencer par euh
l'ancien président donc qui je je l'ai
dit dans mon propos introductif il a été
abondamment critiqué
euh donc ça sera intéressant de savoir
l'évolution depuis son départ de la
fédération mais surtout il y a plusieurs
choses qui ont été dites et sur
lesquelles on aimerait des précisions
donc vous avez évoqué madame Nouri la
des consultations avec appel d'offre euh
alors est-ce que ça veut dire qu'il y en
avait pas avant les appels d'offre donc
ça ça il faudrait nous nous le préciser
vous avez indiqué également avoir changé
je sais pas si c'est mis à jour la fiche
de poste du DT
en conformité avec ses attributions
est-ce que vous pouvez nous préciser ce
que vous voulez dire par là est-ce que
ça veut dire qu'avant il occupait des
fonctions qui n'étaient pas les siennes
euh vous avez indiqué également avoir
mis en place la formation des
entraîneurs et d'autres personnes et
alors dans ce cas là comment ça se passa
avant mais peut-être madame péchel vous
pourrez aussi répondre làdessus sur la
formation des personnes au sein de cette
fédération vous avez évoqué également
une mise en place d'une procédure de
mise en concurrence est-ce que cela veut
dire aussi que avant votre arrivée il
n'y avait pas de procédure de mise en
concurrence
euh appel à prestation extérieure donc
vous avez évoqué la communication
l'événement ciel notamment euh pareil
est-ce que vous pouvez nous préciser de
quoi on parle exactement et et et de
combien on parle aussi exactement
euh ensuite vous avez parlé d'omerta
institutionnalisé est-ce que vous pouvez
nous préciser ce que vous entendez par
là
euh parce que je pense que que c'est
important parce que c'est aussi le cœur
de cette commission d'enquête vu qu'on a
eu beaucoup de témoignages de victimes
qui nous ont évoqué l'omerta qui régé au
sein du mouvement sportif dans plusieurs
fédérations et plusieurs
clubs madame péchala peut-être plus
précisément des questions qui vous
concerne vous avez indiqué avoir intégré
le CNOSF est-ce que vous pouvez juste
peut-être nous préciser la date l'année
à laquelle vous avez intégré le CNOSF
juin 2021 juin 2021 donc vous avez
évoqué une prise de parole en 2017 avec
plusieurs personnes vous avez dit vous
avez dit là autour de la table il y a au
moins 4 C personnes qui sont concernées
est-ce que c'était dans le casadre du
CNOSF et est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire qui était présent à ce
moment-là lors de cette
réunion c'est la donc c'est la
commission des athlètes de haut niveau
honnêtement c'était 6 ans je sais plus
qui était autour de la table mais ça se
retrouve forcément dans les PV donc
c'est une commission qui est je dirais
indépendante c'est-à-dire que ce qui ce
qui est dit n'est pas
forcément en fait j'en sais rien
j'espère que c'est porté au plus haut
niveau sinon ça ne sert à rien mais oui
on en enfin on j'en ai parlé mais
c'était un moment où c'était encore un
tabou et et la réaction a été de baisser
les yeux de baisser le la tête mais je
ne veux pas
l'interpréter est-ce que vous savez
est-ce que vous savez par exemple si
monsieur massaglia était présent lors
non non non il était pas là c'est juste
entre athlètes d'accord et donc ces
informations là une fois qu'elles ont
été livrées dans ce comité vous ne savez
pas où elles ont été euh où elles ont
été transmis non non parce que moi
j'étais juste membre de cette commission
je n'étais pas coprésidente donc c'est
pas moi qui fixait l'ordre du jour et je
ne sais pas si ça a été porter justement
sur le compte-rendu de de cette réunion
moi j'ai simplement voulu alerter sur
les statistiques dramatiques qui
commençaient à sortir par rapport au VI
sexuelle sur le terrain
sportif très bien euh bah du coup je
vais peut-être vous laisser commencer
par répondre à à toutes ces questions
puis ensuite j'en aurai
d'autres bien sûr je vous remercie euh
donc j'ai j'ai pris quelques notes hein
puisque c'est vrai que il y a plusieurs
questions qui qui qui s'enchaînent euh
juste une une petite chose parce que
c'est vrai que ça ça me tient à cœur euh
j'ai entendu donc Madame péchalin
répéter et dire que effectivement
j'étais un pion de l'ancien euh euh
comment dire président de la Fédération
euh j'ai cru et je répète très
honnêtement ce que j'ai toujours dit
j'ai cru à son rôle de conseiller à un
moment c'est vrai qu'il avait soutenu ma
campagne j'ai cru à son côté expert en
sport et j'ai eu tort et les choses ont
largement changé et très vite donc c'est
une petite précision que je tenais
malgré tout à apporter puisque tout a
été stoppé et j'ai eu le courage de
rompre cette
situation peut-être juste sur ce point
précis puisque vous vous
l'évoquez est-ce que aujourd'hui donc ce
que vous nous dites c'est que monsieur
gayag n'a plus de rôle du tout à la
Fédération des sports de glace même
officieux au sein de la fédération alors
exactement c'està-dire qu'aujourd'hui il
y a aucun rôle il n'en a jamais eu même
officiellement et il y en a encore moins
officieusement alors
je juste pour préciser le rapport de l'
l'igsesr de 2023 oui dénonce la place
prépondérante que prend encore l'ancien
président alors même qu'il n'a plus de
poste à la Fédération et il y a
plusieurs pages de ce rapport qui
l'indique effectivement je je vous l'ai
dit je le pensais être conseiller
j'avais envie de réunir un maximum de
compétences autour de moi puisque ma
marque de fabrique c'est vraiment de
gouverner avec une c certain unité en
équipe je le pensais peut-être
conseiller et encore une fois je le
répète ça a été un grand tort alors
depuis quand vous ne faites plus du tout
appel à ces services même en tant que
conseiller alors c'est ça a été très
très vite he c'est vrai que c'est
peut-être assez incroyable à croire mais
ça a été très très vite d dès l'été qui
a suivi mon élection ça a été compliqué
seulement voilà il fallait être dans une
certaine stratégie pour que justement je
puisse
reprendre complètement les reennes de
cette fédération et notamment j'ai envie
de de saluer encore une fois l'arrivée
de Monsieur Jamel cheek qui est qui a
été nommé au 1er novembre ça a été une
rencontre formidable une belle surprise
et évidemment c'est enchaîné aussi
l'arrivée de ma secrétaire générale et à
nous trois nous faisions cette équipe
forte unie qui nous a permis de de
braver toutes ces tempêtes madame
péchala je vu que vous aviez levé la
main est-ce que vous pouvez juste voilà
éteindre le micro je travaille pour
Eurosport je vais sur les grands
événements sportifs et j'étais à la
finale des Grands Prix en décembre 2022
où j'ai croisé monsieur gayag portant
une accréditation donc représentant
officiellement la Fédération française
des sports de
glace il y a eu des membres proches de
gayag c'estàdire du bureau qui ont été
éjectés il y a quelques mois 6 et je
m'étonne simplement de voir encore
madame Stéphanie Daval secrétaire
général et Madame Ganel nouris encore
dans la Fédération puisque le Modot
d'ord c'était d'enlever enfin de faire
sortir les proches de Monsieur
gayagé moi j'ai des preuves on le sait
tous ils étaient très proches avant les
élections et au moins jusqu'en décembre
2022 moi j'appelle ça le bal des
foucus donc peut-être est-ce qu'on peut
revenir sur ce calendrier parce que pour
le coup le rapport il date de 2023 et ce
qui est indiqué là-dedans est quand même
assez clair sur le fait qu'il a une
encore une présence très importante donc
est-ce que alors quand vous nous dites
dès le début vous mettez
fin à finalement à son rôle de
conseiller donc visiblement jusqu'en
décembre 2022 il avait encore des
accréditations il représentait la
Fédération est-ce que peut-être nous
expliquez comment ça se fait bien sûr en
fait cette accréditation n'a jamais été
donnée par moi-même et c'est quelque
chose que j'avais déjà signalé lors de
l'inspection général voilà nous avons un
certain monde d'ailleurs de
disysfonctionnement sur notre système
informatique et je pense que mes codes
avaient été
utilisés je l'avais signalé à
l'Inspection
générale et vous avez entamé une
procédure en interne pour savoir qui
avait pu utiliser vos
codes alors il y avait pas de procédure
en interne mais pour autant c'est vrai
que lorsqu'il y a eu notamment
l'éviction des 6 et je ne considère pas
comme étant une proche de Monsieur gayer
euh il y a eu vol de données aussi et là
une plainte a été déposé alors si je
vous demande d'être vraiment précis sur
les dates c'est parce que au-delà de la
question de de de de l'année c'est que
le rapport de l'inspection date de juin
2023 donc on est vraiment sur cet été et
c'est indiqué noir sur blanc donc
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui fait penser
du coup à
l'isgser dans ce rapport que monsieur
gayaga est encore très présent dans la
Fédération pourquoi ils ont écrit cela
si ce n'est plus le cas alors si c'est
vrai que le le rapport a été publié
tardivement c'était d'ailleurs juste
avant notre assemblée générale début
juin il était attendu c'est sûr pour
autant il y a eu des des faits
marquants
notamment le le le le voyage au Japon où
les personnes qui étaient concernées ont
exprimé très clairement leur
position de demande de retour de
Monsieur gayag je me suis fermement
opposé à ça c'est suite à cette
situation que j'ai proposé donc
à évidemment un près concertation avec
mon be qui était divisé quand même à
l'époque il faut le le reconnaître mais
j'ai proposé donc à mon conseil fédéral
la sortie de ces personnes et suite au
vote cette sortie a été validée à plus
de 80
%. alors puisque juste madame péchala
vous avez évoqué le rapport justement en
disant que ça va être confirmé dans le
enfin est-ce que vous pouvez nous
confirmer ce qu'il y a dans le rapport
sur la la présence de
Monsieur G moi j'ai pas eu l'intégralité
du rapport de liig j'ai eu simplement
les parties qui concernent en gros c'est
120 pages sur plus de 800 il me semble
donc je peux juste vous confirmer que je
l'ai vu avec cette accréditation que je
connais le système effectivement le
président et la seule personne à pouvoir
autoriser ses accréditations il y a un
seul membre de l'instance qui est qui
qui a cette possibilité d'aller sur le
terrain voilà c'est c'est très cadré par
la Fédération
Internationale je peux pas en dire plus
je peux juste vous dire que les membres
qui ont été vincés du bureau sont aussi
des membres qui sont rentrés au bureau
donc pendant les élections de juin
2022 est-ce que vous pouvez répondre aux
différentes questions que j'ai j'ai pu
vous poser
voilà oui bien sûr je je vais continuer
donc effectivement concernant les appels
d'offre donc aujourd'hui elles sont
systématique ça n'était pas le cas
auparavant nous sommes donc en total
respect du règlement financier he qui
stipule qu' en fonction de certains
montants il faut faire cette
confrontation donc c'est parfaitement le
cas aujourd'hui alors quand vous avez
quand vous êtes arrivé à la Fédération
je crois que d'ailleurs dans un
entretien à l'OPS de mai 2023 vous
indiquez je n'imaginais pas un un
univers aussi catastrophique et corrompu
et donc il y a la question des marchés
publics que vous venez d'évoquer est-ce
que tout cela a été signalé quelque part
sur la le fait qu'il y avait pas de
marché public enfin tout ce que vous
avez dénoncé là est-ce que vous l'avez
signalé quelque
part alors c'est vrai que ça c'est parti
d'un d'un constat et notamment sur la
partie événementielle où je pense qu'il
y avait énormément de de copinage et pas
forcément de de réel appel
voilà au niveau du du
signalement ça a été notre notre
réaction notre notre meilleure réponse
évidemment nous avons
rétabli la situation le le plus vite
possible
euh concernant j'enchaîne peut-être les
questions si vous êtes d'accord
concernant le rôle du DTN ben écoutez
aujourd'hui je vais vous expliquer tout
à l'heure dans la présentation que nous
avions cette CRTF donc la commission de
rvision des textes fédéraux euh très
clairement le rôle du dtien n'était même
pas inscrit et n'est pas prévu dans nos
statuts alors c'est quand même assez
formidable c'est vrai que moi aussi je
vais être dans le constat jusque-là on
avait quand même un turnover de dtien
qui était assez incroyable he c'était
jamais plus de 2 ans je pense que tout
ça s'explique par le fait aussi que la
gouvernance d'avant était une
gouvernance centré autour d'une personne
et aujourd'hui ce n'est absolument pas
le cas j'avance main dans la main avec
mon DTN et c'est vraiment à mon sens la
la la clé de de la réussite et ça se
traduit évidemment par je pense une
sérénité un bien-être pour nos sportifs
et les résultats sont les meilleures
preuves juste est-ce que vous P vous
pouvez préciser parce que vous indiquez
que c'était pas dans le règlement donc
vous l'avez ajouté alors quelles sont
les attributions qu'est-ce que vous avez
modifier justement dans alors dans les
Tage de du T j'ai envie de dire alors
c'est vrai que je pourrais vous fournir
un
détail enfin des des choses beaucoup
plus précises mais ça fait parfaitement
partie des attribution normale du du DTN
mais je pense que la normalité n'était
pas forcément présente et voilà je pense
que c'est plus rétablir le le rôle qu'un
DTN doit avoir c'est-à-dire s'occuper
réellement des sportifs de de haut
niveau et d'ailleurs je vais enchaîner
sur la la
question suivante concernant la la
formation continue donc c'est une
formation qu'on avait envie de remettre
en place donc une formation continue
pour nos
entraîneurs pour pour d'autres également
et
évidemment en réaction à à tout ce que
on a à faire aujourd'hui par rapport au
problèmes notamment de de violence et de
sensibilisation vous indiquez remettre
en place cette formation ça veut dire
qu'elle a été arrêtée à un
moment bah écoutez je je n'ai pas
forcément suffisamment de de recul mais
j' imagine que c'est quelque chose de
prévu le métier d'entraîneur est
vraiment un métier dans lequel il faut
être tout le temps à la page j'ai envie
de dire donc forcément je je pense que
c'est pas l'obtention d'un diplôme et
ensuite on ne fait plus rien aujourd'hui
en plus au vu de l'évolution de la
société je pense qu'il est essentiel de
continuer à à sensibiliser et à former
nos entraîneurs et justement si je
m'attarde un petit peu sur le volet euh
de des violences je suis très fière
aujourd'hui puisque ça a été suivi à à
plus que 300 % j'ai envie de dire de de
mettre cette partie sensibilisation et
formation pour nos jeunes au niveau des
brevets fédéraux donc ce sont ces
brevets initiateurs qui touchent nos
premiers bénévoles au niveau des clubs
et encore une fois au niveau de la
labellisation de nos clubs donc l'école
française de glace qui est la strate une
de cette labellisation qui est
reconduite pour 2000
222026 la condition sinequanon pour
obtenir cette première strate qui est
vraiment le début incontournable est la
sensibilisation et la formation de
l'ensemble de nos dirigeants ou toute
personne étant en contact avec nos
licenciés de suivre cette formation sous
forme de webinaire ça a été une belle
réussite et aujourd'hui on a quand même
pas mal de clubs labellisés et ce n'est
pas fini alors du coup madame péchala
sur la question de la formation puisque
si ce n'était pas en place au moment où
vous êtes arrivé quen était-il sous
votre présidence est-ce que vous pouvez
juste éteindre le micro s'il vous plaît
madame nourie
pardon la formation continue des
entraîneurs elle s'est arrêtée avec la
crise sanitaire avec les patinoires qui
se sont fermés et avec l'incapacité de
se regrouper elle a repris si mon
souvenir est bon mais je dirais dans le
2è semestre 2021 avec un point d'org
lors des Championnats du Monde qu' que
nous organisions fin mars 2022
alors du coup juste est-ce qu'on peut se
caler sur les dates parce que si ça a
repris en 2021 donc au moment où vous
êtes arrivé il y avait des formations
euh bah écoutez moi de ce que j'ai
retenu et de ce que j'ai eu en retour je
je n'ai pas eu ce constat et pour preuve
l'infmg est en total sommeil depuis un
certain temps et donc avoir l'utilité de
le réactiver ou pas en tout cas il va
falloir reprendre tout ce qui est des
certifications notamment callaliopi mais
aujourd'hui c'est en total arrêt et et
c'est comme ça dans les dans l'état que
je l'ai récupérer bon alors du coup si
il y avait pas de formation au moment de
l'arrivée de Madame Nouri comment vous
expliquez que du coup elle s redémarré
avant enfin juste faut qu'on arrive à se
mettre d'accord sur à quel moment les
formations ont repris si c'est le cas et
si c'est pas le cas pourquoi et donc que
vous les ayez remis en
place les formations je l'ai pas inventé
il y a eu cette formation continue des
entraîneurs avec comm point d'org les
championnats du monde en mars à
Montpellier demander aux entraîneurs sur
le terrain demander à l'ancien
DTN je sais pas quoi vous dire d'autre
si Madame Nour n'a pas
l'information quelles étaient ces
formations quelles étaient ces
formations une formation continue des
entraîneurs de patinage
artistique et de dans sur glace
alors dans ces formations continues
est-ce que il y a un volet lutte contre
les VSS qui est intégré dans ce
dispositif de formation continue je pose
la question à toutes les deux toute
honnêeté je n'ai pas le contenu de la
formation ça c'est vraiment propre au
DTN et donc à toute au pôle formation
par contre ce que je peux dire quand
même c'est que quand je suis arrivée on
a conventionné assez rapidement avec
l'association donc colosse au pied
d'argile et il y a eu des formations
disp
ANC sur plusieurs jours sur tous les
cadres techniques sportifs de la
fédération et des sensibilisations qui
ont été faites lors des regroupements
fédéraux donc sur nos
jeunes C il me semble et il y a eu il me
semble aussi entre 10 et 15
sensibilisations sur tous les
territoires parce que l'idée c'était de
donner l'opportunité à des donc je dis
bien des territoires parce que c'était
pas par Lig donc ça dépendait voilà de
la situation géographique ils avaient la
possibilité de s'organiser de choisir
l'association avec laquelle il voulait
travailler pour sensibiliser l'ensemble
des
encadrants donc les présidents et les
entraîneurs il s'étaaient couplés à une
formation technique h voilà il y en a eu
entre 10 et 15 à quel moment est-ce que
vous mettez en place le partenariat avec
colos au pied
d'argile je crois en juin
2020 en avant l'été
2020 ok donc il y avait formation
continue le partenar colos au P d'argile
donc Madame Nouri vous vous nous
indiquez que vous remettez en place des
formations qui n'existaient pas sauf que
là nous indique que les formations
étaient mises en place donc est-ce que
c'était des formations différent est-ce
que ce n'est pas les formations
continues que vraiment est-ce que vous
pouvez préciser parce que je pense que
personne ne comprend
là voilà le fait que l'une d'entre vous
indique qu'il y avait des formations qui
étaient maintenu et que l'autre nous
indique au moment où elle prend la
présidence il y avait pas de formation
bah écoutez moi je voudrais juste et
j'aimerais entendre quelles sont ces
formations continues qui ont été mises
en place voilà de manière à être le plus
clair possible moi aujourd'hui
effectivement avec mon équipe je mets en
place un certain nombre de formations
évidemment avec une priorité pour la
lutte contre les LVS et toute violence
possible et évidemment j'ai j'ai aussi
par rapport au au volet technique des
des propositions à faire et pour être
complètement dans le positif également
ce projet de de reconversion d'une part
de nos sportifs de haut niveau mais
aussi proposer donc pour la suite à nos
licenciés des passerelles des
passerelles pour se voler peut-être un
petit peu spectacle et dans ces cas-là
justement j'aimerais apporter aussi
cette cette compétence à nos entraîneurs
et sans oublier aussi de de pouvoir les
aider à faire face à un fléo que l'on a
au niveau de de des problèmes
énergétiques avec des patinoires qui
ferment avec des délais qui qui se
rallongent sans glace et où il ne faut
pas laisser à mon sens des entraîneurs
dépourvus donc c'est vrai qu'on a aussi
on est en pleine écriture de cette
formation à proposer pour Pier à tout ça
et peut-être euh avoir notamment une vue
sur le inline puisque c'est une licence
qu'on a remis en place madame Nouri
est-ce qu'au moment où vous arrivez à la
présidence de la fédération est-ce que
le partenariat avec colossse auoped
d'argile était déjà mis en place oui
tout à fait donc est-ce que coloss au
pied d'argile faisait de l'information
et de la formation et de
l'accompagnement des victimes au moment
où vous prenez la présidence de la
fédération alors sur ce volet là oui je
pense que il y a il y a pas de souci
là-dessus je vous cache pas que dans un
souci de complémentarité parce que
vraiment c'est quelque chose qui me
tient à cœur euh je je tiens à ajouter
au à cette association colosse au pied
d'argile qui fait déjà un très grand
travail d'autres associations et
notamment avec ce projet Sentinel que je
vous ai exposé tout à l'heure je suis
ravie de voir que j'ai un certain nombre
de de bonne volonté c'est comme ça que
je je vais les appeler en tout cas des
personnes qui se proposent à venir
renforcer cette équipe de de terrain sur
place de manière à compléter et
améliorer encore plus aider nos
différents référents intégrité alors je
vais revenir sur la question de l'omerta
puisque y compris dans le cadre de cette
commission les victimes qu'on a pu
entendre encore beaucoup beaucoup de
personnes nous parlent d'omerta dans le
mouvement sportif et dans plusieurs
clubs et fédération peut-être l'une et
l'autre votre regard vous vous avez
évoqué par exemple l'omerta
institutionnalisé donc j'aimerais
vraiment que vous reveniez dessus parce
que ça me semble important euh de
pouvoir nous expliquer ce que vous
entendez par là et peut-être madame
pêche là ensuite sur la sur la sur
l'omerta s'il vous plaît bah écoutez al
c'est c'est encore une sorte de de de de
gros ressentis hein c'est que voilà
aujourd'hui il faut vraiment euh
lever toutes ces choses qu'on a
peut-être caché on a aussi récupéré
certaines affaires euh qu'il faut euh
qu'il faut élucider et notamment euh je
je n'ai pas hésité à à me rapprocher
donc du ministère du cabinet de Madame
la Ministre alors quand vous quand vous
indiquer que vous avez récupéré
certaines affaires qu'il vous faut
élucider donc est-ce qu'on parle bien de
VSS
ou d'autres affaires aussi de violence
que dont vous avez hérité en prenant la
présidence qui n'ont pas été
traité
alors il y a des affaires qui sont
toujours en cours je pense que Madame
péchala on avait également connaissance
he je pense à celle qui est du côté
transatlantique et que nous sommes en
train de de de traiter également donc en
changeant un petit peu certaines donnes
puisque nous avons changé d'avocat et
aujourd'hui je je je suis dans l'attente
du du
retour du du procès mais nous avons eu
gain de cause en plaidant notamment
l'incompétence de
territoire je ne vous cache pas que je
me suis rapprochée du cabin in de madame
la ministre qui n'était pas au courant
et découvrait cette
affaire madame péchala oui sur cette
affaire c'est c'est je ve juste préciser
que c'est aussi un dossier que j'ai
hérité de mon
prédécesseur c'est une affaire qui s'est
passée en 2017 sur le territoire
américain et qui a explosé dans les
médias en
2019 voilà
oui est-ce que vous pouvez préciser de
quelle affaire vous parlez s'il vous
plaît parce qu'il y en a eu qu même je
peux le faire publiquement là bah si
c'est déjà dans les médias vous pouvez
oui c'est l'affaire Morgan
cypré vous voulez oui vous pouvez nous
en
parler euh Morgan Cypre donc était un
sportif de haut niveau euh qui
s'entraînait en Floride donc avec destin
enfin des entraîneurs américain sa
partenaire qui
était évidemment française donc il
représentait la France il préparait les
Jeux olympiques de Pang Chang
2018 je je je la fait au conditionnel
hein parce que je évidemment j'étais pas
là donc
h monsieur gayag aurait eu
vent de sexto envoyé de la part de de
Morgan Cypre à à une jeune patineuse
âgée de 13 ans
américaine lui aurait demandé de se
taire en disant qu'il allait
s'occuper de tout
ça et puis bah c'est sorti 2 ans après
euh la victime a porté plainte à alerté
safe sport Center ce qui est une sorte
de comité éthique aux
États-Unis voilà et quand j'étais à la
Fédération donc on s'est occupé de cette
affaire là avec le cabinet d'avocat et
euh les dommages et intérêts demandés
s'élevé enfin pouvait s'élever jusqu'à
plus de 5 millions de dollars ce qui
n'est pas rien donc c'est une affaire
qu'on a pris extrêmement au
sérieux en fait la la
principale source de problème c'était
que la Fédération Française et sports de
glace rémunérer
directement les entraîneurs américains
voilà ce qui donne une sorte de
hiérarchie sur ah oui que l'entraîneur
amricain aurait aussi été au
courant je pense que ça va là sur les
grandes lignes ça suffira alors
euh ce qui nous intéresse nous c'est
surtout de savoir ce qu'a fait la
fédération à ce moment-là
puisque monsieur gag donc était
président de la Fédération il aurait
donc demandé de de rien dire puisquil
traiterait l'affaire vous dites qu'elle
explose donc médiatiquement en
2019 est-ce qu'un signalement enfin
qu'est-ce qui a été fait en interne de
la fédération
ok donc ça ça je suis beaucoup plus à
l'aise que ça à partir du moment où je
suis présente à la Fédération donc moi
je sais qu'il y a cette affaire qui est
qui est dans les cartons qui a des
lettres qui arrivent régulièrement du
cabinet américain qui nous demande de
prendre cette affaire au sérieux parce
que justement les dommages à intérêt
peuvent s'élever
voilà je suis contactée à l'été 2020 par
self Sports Center on me demande de de
communiquer les coordonnées de la
référente intégrité de la fédéra
ce que je fais et en décembre 2020 je
suis alertée par différents médias c'est
enfin via l'attaché de presse que
différents médias
euh évoquent l'histoire cette affaire
Morgan cipre et on m'appelle une fois
deux fois trois fois dans la matiné en
me disant mais il y a eu des nouvelles
est-ce que est-ce que tu peux répondre
au journaliste mais j'étais au courant
de rien et après trois ou quatre appels
supplémentaires je me suis dit c'est pas
possible il se passe quelque chose et et
je suis passée à côté donc j'ai demandé
à la référente intégrité de regarder si
elle avait rien reçu de la part de C
sport Center effectivement elle avait
reçu un mail en septembre
euh
h euh avec des preuves assez
éloquente sauf que nous on avait déjà
fait passer cette affaire devant la
commission disciplinaire donc à l'été
2020 on peut pas rejuger la la même
personne pour les mêmes faits donc je
pouvais pas saisir à nouveau la
commission disciplinaire de qu'avait
décidé la commission disciplinaire en
juin
2022 la commission disciplinaire comme
la plupart des affaires si ce n'est
l'ensemble des affaires et classer sans
suite parce qu'en fait on a un souci au
sein des fédération c'est que la
commission
disciplinaire n'a pas le pouvoir de
mener une
instruction mais je dirais avec les
moyens qui nous permettrai de recueillir
des éléments donc dans le meilleur des
cas et c'était l'histoire enfin ça
concernait cette affaire dans le
meilleur des cas le chargé d'instruction
va présenter une sorte de revue de
presse mais les membres qui sont donc
des personnes compétentes et enfin à
l'époque étai des
membres des avocats honoraires disait
qu'il y avait pas assez d'éléments pour
pour pour donner des suites dans dans
ces dossers mais donc vous le traitez en
interne de la fédération mais est-ce
queil y a un signalement qui a été fait
au ministère des sport à ce moment-là
est-ce que vous avez averti le ministère
de cette affaire à ce moment-là est-ce
que par exemple pour euh protéger la
victime est-ce queil y a un article 40
qui a été déclenché est-ce qu'il y a une
plainte qui a été déposée non non
c'était le tout début de toute de toutes
ces procédures et honnêtement je je ne
suis pas sûre je je crois je ne suis pas
sûre je ne suis pas
sûre mais vous étiez présidente de la
fédération à l'époque ouais donc en fait
ce que je n'arrive pas à comprendre
c'est pourquoi personne quand on a eu
quand vous avez été informé par les
Américains enfin par les États-Unis de
cette affaire pourquoi personne n'a
prévenu le le ministère des Sports
pourquoi il y a pas eu de enfin parce
que il y a bien sûr la mesure
disciplinaire à l'intérieur de la
Fédération vous pouvez même faire une
enquête administrative au niveau du
ministère il peut y avoir une enquête
judiciaire aussi et en fait on a
l'impression que ça s'est arrêté à la
commission disciplinaire et il s'est
rien passé ensuite non il y avait une
enquête judiciaire qui qui était ouverte
aux États-Unis donc ça avait lieu sur le
territoire américain et le ministère
était prévenu en France oui je crois
qu'on l' informé parce que le les les
dommages inter étaient tellement
élevés alors juste une dernière question
vous dites que la personne la
référente intérité intégrité avait reçu
le mail en septembre et donc elle ne
l'avait pas vu comment ça se fait qu'on
rate un mail comme ça exactement comment
ça se fait qu'on r un mail comme ça donc
elle m'a dit qu'elle ne parlait pas
anglais je lu dis mais dans le doute tu
me l'envoies et Morgan en anglais ça se
dit aussi Morgan cipre donc
je veux pas faire de faux procès
mais c'était quelqu'un qui était proche
de Didier
gayage je ne sais pas si c'est si c'est
quelque chose qui a été intentionnel ou
pas je ne sais pas si elle s'est rendu
compte de la gravité du problème et il
faut quand même remettre en perspective
que les élus au sein des fédérations
sont des
bénévole du coup c'est compliqué euh
de de secouer quelqu'un qui donne de son
temps vous avez donc elle reçoit ce mail
en septembre vous n'êtes pas informé
vous nous indiquez que dans ce mail il y
a des éléments probants de preuve
qu'est-ce qui se passe à ce momentl au
moment où vous découvrez le mail
qu'est-ce qui se passe parce que vous ne
pouvez plus faire la commission
disciplinaire donc qu'est-ce qui a mis
en place maisah c'était ça a été le
souci c'est qu'il a fallu trouver une
autre instance pour pouvoir instruire à
nouveau cette affaire donc je me suis
tournée vers le CNOSF mais ils n'ont pas
d'organes disciplinaire et j'ai demandé
à Denis je dit il faut que tu m'aides il
faut absolument qu'on trouve quelque
chose parce qu'on ne peut pas rester
sans rien faire dans cette affaire mais
il y avait rien à faire donc notre
chance quelque part c'était que c'était
une affaire qui avait eu lieu aux
États-Unis et donc j'ai sollicité la
Fédération internationale de patinage
pour qu'elle puisse juger cette affaire
et elle a une commission
disciplinaire mais au début ça a été une
fin de non recevoir parce que j'avais
dépassé le délai à partir du moment où
j'avais les éléments mais je les avais
pas eu moi directement m propre ça
datait de septembre je crois que c'était
60 jours donc là on avait dépassé donc
j'ai insister insister insister pour que
ça puisse passer dans la commission
disciplinaire ce qui a été le cas et la
fin de l'histoire c'est la même que ce
qui s'est passé en France fin de nous
recevoir parce qu'il n'y a pas assez euh
d'éléments parce que ça ne mais vous
nous dites que dans le mail il y avait
des des éléments prob oui mais je suis
pas moi je je suis pas membre de la
commission disciplinaire de la
Fédération Internationale je vous donne
simplement le la la conclusion de cette
commission donc les éléments probants je
suppose que c'était puisque on parle de
de message c'était des captures d'écran
de message c'était euh h ouais à
caractère sexuel oui et des échanges
aussi entre la mère de la
victime et Morgane
oui
i en 2000 je vous passeer la parole tout
de suite donc vous avez alerté Monsieur
donimasseglia H et à ce moment-là même
s'il n'y a pas de commission
disciplinaire au sein du CNOSF est-ce
qu'il vous dirige vers quelqu'un d'autre
est-ce que le ministère est alerté à ce
moment-là non il y a pas de il y a pas
de solution je vous dis la chance c'est
notre chance c'est que ça a eu lieu
finalement sur le sur le territoire
américain non il n'y avait pas les
dispositifs faut pas oublier que c'est
Roxana maracinanou he qui a lancé tout
ce grand projet de lutte contre les
violence 2019- 2020 on est au tout début
des dispositifs on est au tout début de
la prise de conscience et en plus il
faut se mettre en conformité dans les
fédérations il faut que ça suive dans
tout le mouvement sportif donc on n pas
du tout on n'est pas 3 ans c'est énorme
sur ce sur ce sujet alors madame Nouri
peut-être sur cette affaire puisque vous
avez pris la suite oui merci je je vais
apporter quelques éclaircissements parce
que c'est vrai que il y a quand même des
des éléments qui sont pour moi très très
importants et qui se sont vraiment
déroués euh donc en tant que présidente
nouvelle présidente de la Fédération
française des sports de glace à l'été
dernier euh j'ai été contacté euh
plusieurs fois j'ai eu des relances
parce que comme je vous l'ai expliqué on
avait des problèmes informatiques et des
mails qui n'avaient pas été délivré donc
je n'en avais pas eu connaissance les
choses se sont rétablies et dès l'été
dernier j'ai pu avoir donc en lien euh
l'avocat de la Fédération donc aux
États-Unis très clairement ça a été son
premier contact avec la Fédération il
était ravi de voir pour la première fois
sa
cliente j'ai provoqué une
visio cette visio a été devant témoin
évidemment j'ai provoqué une
visio et suite à ça je peux vous dire
que moi j'ai été très étonné de de voir
puisqueévidemment j'ai un petit peu
creusé la question de voir que la
Fédération avait quand même dépensé plus
de 250000 € de frais de défense au aux
États-Unis donc je pense que c'est quand
même significatif dans les
comptes et qu'effectivement
euh le le le le l'avocat qui était aux
États-Unis était en lien avec le cabinet
racine à l'époque en charge de de de la
partie juridique pour la Fédération euh
il ne parlait pas du tout français donc
c'est vrai que c'était c'était pas
simple ça a été je je raconte cette
anecdote parce que ça a été un des
facteurs qui a fait qu'on avait vraiment
envie de changer d'avocat en plus des
factures d'honorair qui nous semblaient
exorbitantes pour une fédération c'était
juste pas possible et évidemment suite à
à ce contact l'affaire a repris les
plaignants ont ont voulu aller au-delà
et le risque puisque je rappelle qu'on
était en Floride dans le compté de Pasco
c'est c'est puni euh de façon xxx XL ce
qui veut dire que le risque financier
s'élevait non pas 5 millions mais au
minimum 5 millions entre 5 millions et
20 millions d'euros ce qui voulait dire
très concrètement plus de fédération
j'ai contacté immédiatement le ministère
et je vous le confirme le ministère
n'était pas au courant de cette
affaire alors moi j'ai juste une demande
de précision puisque il y a eu 250000 €
de dépensé en frais d'avocat donc si euh
la enfin le cabinet aux États-Unis n'a
eu contact avec personne au niveau de la
Fédération Française comment ces 250000
€ ont atterri en fait en frais de
défense aux États-Unis ben écoutez moi
ce que j'ai constaté c'est que les
factures elles arrivaient elles
arrivaient il ne se passaient rien et ça
c'était juste intolérable pour moi donc
évidemment nous avons très vite décidé
de changer d'avocat et pour la petite
histoire euh en un laps de temps de 1
mois non seulement nous avons largement
baissé les frais d'honorair hein on est
rentré dans des des des sommes un petit
peu plus accepbles puisque la provision
sur nos comptes hein était descendue à
au grand maximum 150000 € et encore on
avait vu large puisqu'on les a pas
utilisé euh mais c'est surtout que à
l'issue euh puisque'il y avait une
échéance fin août à l'issue de de ce
procès euh nous avons gagné euh cette
partie puisque nous avons plaidé euh
l'incompétence de territoire et euh
hormis le le délai de 30 jours d'appel
qui j'espère euh va bientôt se se
terminer j'attends euh l'ordonnance
écrite euh ferait que cette histoire
pourrait euh envisager une fin euh la
plus favorable poss possible pour la
Fédération et pour la victime j'espère
et ben oui oui infin parce que c'est ça
le plus important exct j'entends la
question de la fédération mais il y a
quand même une victime dans cette
affaire et il y a une responsabilité de
la Fédération euh alors vous avez compr
plattement raison c'est vrai que là on
est parti pleinement sur l'aspect
financier qui m'avait aussi aussi
révolté mais on est bien d'accord que la
priorité c'est la sécurité et évidemment
le bien-être de l'ensemble de la
population nos licenci en premier mais
l'ensemble de notre population madame
péchala sur les frais d'avocat et le
fait que voilà qu' que a pas eu de
contact al le ministère des Sports éta
informé ça n'était pas le même ça
n'était pas Amélie oua Castera c'était
Roxana marassenanou
voilà d'autre
part quand je suis partie de la
Fédération j'ai pris 3 jours pour clore
l'ensemble de mes dossiers et j'ai
envoyé donc par thématique il y avait
évidemment une thématique alors juste je
vais vous demander de préciser parce que
en fait certes ce n'était pas les mêmes
ministres mais il y a une direction des
sports qui
elle alors qui voilà qui était au
courant au ministère des sport est-ce
que c le est-ce que c'est la direction
le cabin de la minist était directrice
donc Fabien BOURD était au courant donc
elle n'a pas changé elle est toujours là
et donc elle vous dit qu'elle n'est pas
au courant
elle était dans les mails que j'ai
envoyé quand j'ai j'ai j'ai clôturé tous
mes dossiers donc il y avait un mail
donc éthique que j'ai envoyé à Madame
Nouri mais aussi à l'ensemble des
membres du conseil d'administration pour
être sûr justement que tout le monde a
les bonnes information en précisant euh
les urgences où nous en étions et les
contacts qui qui allaient avec dans la
bonneuité des dossiers et j'ai fait ça
par thématique sur l'ensemble euh des
sujets euh qui était porté par la
Fédération voilà ok donc vous vous
transmettez tout à Madame fiden bourde
et j'ai également transmis le dossier en
main propre à Madame Nouri de cette
affaire Morgan CPRE je trouve ça assez
dingue qu'elle ait mis un an et demi à
se souvenir que que ça existait en main
propre à la Fédération il y avait donc
tout les photos le texte c'est un
dossier comme ça c'est un grand
classeur donc alors jeux dire très
franchement je sais pas pourquoi il y a
ce rappel parce que oui ce classeur
existe mais il ne explique en rien le
traitement de de de cette affaire voilà
dans les démarches en tout cas sur le
continent américain et donc le ministère
des Sports vous vous indique qu'il
n'était pas informé non le ministère des
sport n'était pas au
courant alors euh ce qu'on va vous
demander c'est s'il y a eu des échanges
par mail est-ce que vous pouvez nous
transmettre non je ne peux pas parce que
ma boîte mail fédéral a été fermé euh à
la fin de mon mandat ok bon on demandera
au ministère des Sports donc à ce
moment-là
euh on demandera au ministère des Sports
juste une une dernière question
peut-être là-dessus
euh donc au moment du traitement de
cette affaire donc euh ce qu'on comprend
c'est que le ministère des Sports donc
vous nous dites qu'il a été informé il y
a pas eu alors est-ce que le ministère
des Sports il y a déclenché pas un
article 40 ou pas parce que alors
j'arrive pas très bien à comprendre
parce qu'en fait on comprend plus très
bien euh où l'affaire démarre et il y a
au moment où vous êtes informé il y a il
y a pas encore de procès qui se
déclenche aux États-Unis c'est au tout
début de l'affaire donc en fait vous
faites une procédure disciplinaire à
l'intérieur de la fédération mais il y
avait la possibilité de faire une
enquête administrative judiciaire enfin
il y avait d'autres dispositifs donc
c'est là où en fait j'ai du mal à
comprendre où s'arrête cette
affaire alors où elle s'arrête je n'en
sais rien où elle
commence alors attendez j'essaie de bien
me souvenir moi je suis élu le 14 mars
et mais je sais pas comment te comment
je j'en ai été
informé mais le fait est c'est qu'on a
dû réactiver toute la commission
disciplinaire avant l'été 2020 pour
pouvoir le faire passer en
commission
sûrement par un courrier j'imagine alors
pas de s sport Center parce que ils se
sont ils nous ont sollicité sur la
deuxième partie de l'année
2020 je sais
plus ok bon on va essayer de récupérer
les informations pour comprendre parce
que ce qui nous intéresse nous c'est
justement les dysfonctionnements qui ont
pu donner lieu même si on comprend bien
que le votre prédécesseur avait fait le
choix visiblement de pas informer à
alors qu'il était au courant de cette
situation de ce qu'on comprend et que du
coup vous avez toutes les deux hérités à
tour de rôle de de ce dossier est-ce que
peut-être sans forcément du coup pas sur
ce dossier-là mais dans le cadre de vos
fonctions à toutes les deux est-ce qu'il
vous est est-ce qu'il vous est arrivé de
faire des déclenchements d'article 40 ou
de signalements sur des faits de
violence sexuelle d'hcèlement de
violence physique de racisme euh pendant
votre mandat de de président de
fédération donc peut-être madame péchla
puis madame Nouri s'il vous plaît
oui ça tombe bience que ça me permet
aussi de de faire un petit récap sur sur
la sur le volet éthique donc de la FFG
quand je suis arrivée début 2020 euh
c'était facile hein comme dossier
c'était une page blanche hein il y avait
absolument rien donc tout était à
construire donc on a nommé deux
référentes intégrité une élu l'autre la
DTN on a créé un comité éthique on a
réactivé la la commission disciplinaire
la Fédération Française sport de glace
s'est portée partie civile dans deux
affaires donc qui concernaient des des
violences sexuelles euh avec colosgil
donc la formation des cadres techniques
sportifs euh la sensibilisation lors des
regroupements équipe de France donc
auprès des jeunes 15 actions de
sensibilisation dans les territoires on
a créé des outils de com pour euh pour
pour l'ensemble des clubs pour que les
témoins ou les victimes puissent
justement euh solliciter en tout cas
témoigner euh via la cellule signal
sport et en même temps de mettre les
coordonnées de la référente intégrité
que on est c'est deux biiais là pour
traiter euh leurs témoignages on a créé
des ces de bonne conduite notamment pour
les sportifs de haut niveau mais aussi
pour les encadrants et puis j'ai lancé
le projet sayz donc lutte contre les
violence sexuelle en Europe euh je peux
développer mais bon c'est peut-être pas
pas utile voilà
euh ça c'est les ça c'est les grandes
lignes pendant tout euh donc mon
demi-mandat on a clôturé 15 affaires qui
concneent des violences sexuelles
physiques
ou moral il y en avait six sous arrêtés
préfectoraux voilà et quand je suis
parti il y en avait encore huit en cours
cinq qui concernait des entraîneurs un
qui une affaire qui qui concernait un
patineur et deux des dirigeants il y a
eu 11 11 médiations avec le comité
éthique 10 interventions de
d'associations spécialisées donc pour
suivre et aider les victimes neu cartes
professionnelles suspendues ou retirées
et cinq passages devant la commission
disciplinaire plus quatre saisis est-ce
que vous pouvez juste nous préciser sur
ces sur ces 15 affaires que vous avez
clôturé sous votre demi-mandat est-ce
que c'est des affaires qui étaient déjà
enclenché que vous ou alors c'était des
affaires dont vous aviez connaissance
mais qui n'ont jamais été traité euh ou
alors est-ce que c'était des procédures
qui étaient déjà engagées que vous avez
terminé pour les 3/4 c'est c'était des
des vieilles affaires qui sont
ressorties à ce moment-là puisque la la
parole a été libérée donc mais donc il y
avait déjà une enquête en cours il y
avait déjà eu des signalements de fait
non non il y avait absolument rien on
est vraiment au tout début des
dispositifs de la lutte contre les
violences donc il y a absolument rien il
y a juste cette parole qui se libère et
il y a des gens qui 10 15 20 30 ans
après nous envoyé des des des
témoignages mais est-ce que vous savez
si par exemple votre prédécesseur était
informé de cette non honnêtement je
pense je pense pas d'accord c'était
l'omerta et puis il y avait encore une
fois c'était ça semble pas loin mais
c'était pas la même époque il y avait
pas on savait pas vers qui se tourner
vers qui
s'adresser madame Nouri
oui alors c'est vrai que actuellement
donc la la Fédération et partie civile
pour notamment le le le le cadre des
procè procédure en cours suite aux
articles 40 de l'inspection
générale j'ai également une plainte
contre X en cours et malheureusement je
ne pourrais pas développer le sujet et
j'ai également un article 40 qui a été
déclenché par un de mes référents
intégrité alors vous nous indiquez que
la l'inspection a fait des articles 40
est-ce que ça veut dire que enfin
pourquoi c'est l'inspection qui fait les
articles 40 sur la Fédération sport de
glace alors c'est vrai je je vous l'ai
expliquer tout à
l'heure le cette inspection générale a
été vraiment profitable puisque ça a été
un
travail titanesque en un temps record il
y a certaines choses que je n'ai
peut-être pas eu le temps de voir tout
de suite mais en tout cas oui il y a eu
des articles 40 et puis alors attention
Nathalie péchala l'expliquait tout à
l'heure
également moi dans ma partie de rapport
finalement cette partie est très maigre
puisque je n'ai quelques mois de
gouvernant
et le reste du rapport m'est
complètement occulté donc même au-delà
des articles 40 ils sont pour la plupart
floutés et c'est vrai que de manière à
pouvoir accès aux informations et
pouvoir rebondir le mieux possible parce
que là encore c'est un point d'honneur
que je mets j'attends les conclusions
des différentes procédures et évidemment
je peux vous garantir que la Fédération
française des sports de glace aura la la
la meilleure attitude la bonne attitude
qu'il faudra par rapport à ses affaires
donc c'est pour ça que cette procédure
de partie civile est en
cours alors en 2023 l'ancien champion du
monde de patinage
artistique Brian Jubert a été accusé de
violence dans son club de
Poitier il est par ailleurs soupçonné
d'avoir entretenu une liaison avec une
patineuse mineure comment la Fédération
a traiter cette affaire puisque là c'est
sorti en août
2023 alors justement il y a un certain
nombre de signalements et d'articles 40
alors moi je tiens quand même à à à
signaler que euh je bénéficie du rapport
donc d'une synthèse des signalements qui
arrivent à la Fédération euh je ne suis
pas destinataire je ne les lis pas donc
je n'ai aucun détail de ces signalements
par contre dans notre process euh les
référents intégrité euh peuvent ainsi
que le rapporteur peuvent demander une
saisine de la commission disciplinaire
donc aujourd'hui j'ai se dossiers en
commission disciplinaire et donc là je
suis actrice et je mets en œuvre tout ça
pour pour le reste c'est vrai que
concernant les signalements et leurs
détails déjà c'est sous confidentialité
et je n'y ai pas accès et justement
alors quand il y a des signalements qui
sont faits même si navez vous n'avez pas
accès à l'ensemble du dossier donc vous
avez ces fameuses commissions
disciplinairees euh par exemple sur une
affaire de de comme celle-ci est-ce que
vous prenez des mesures à titre
conservatoire alors la commission
disciplinaire aujourd'hui peut prendre
une mesure conservatoire de manière à
protéger tout le monde et j'insiste tout
le monde euh pour autant ce dossier sera
traité très prochainement début novembre
mais c'est vrai qu'encore une fois je ne
suis pas dans cette boucle et je
confirme la la constitution de cette
commission disciplinaire Nathalie
péchala l'a précisé également tout à
l'heure
elle est constituée de d'avocats qui
sont soit en disponibilité maintenant ou
toujours
actif alors au-delà des articles 40
est-ce qu'il vous est déjà arrivé de
faire des signalements à Signal sport
l'une et
l'autre moi directement jamais puisque
pour moi c'était la mission de la
référente intégrité donc qui était en
lien avec Fabienne BOURD à l'époque et
qui faisait euh qui faisait et euh voilà
la passation de de
données c'est un sujet qui est qui est
complexe l'éthique puisque le président
doit rester en dehors de cette boucle
alors le comité éthique peut enfin sauf
si ça a changé mais on avait fait tout
un process process de traitement selon
la gravité et l'urgence des signalements
qu'on recevait le comité éthique peut
décider de saisir directement la
commission disciplinaire et à ce moment
là j'en suisfin j'en été informé mais
sans cela on n pas le détail des des
signalements
évidemment je parle pas forcément de
signalement qui vous arrive par
l'extérieur mais par exemple tout à
l'heure on a eu des personnes qui nous
ont dit certaines victimes viennent
directement s'adresser à nous et dans ce
cas-là vous avez tout à fait la
possibilité vous en tant que personne
qui recueille cette parole de victime de
faire soit article 40 soit de faire un
dépôt à Signal sport c'était la question
en fait est-ce que vous vous avez déjà
été dans ce cas de figure vous avez eu à
faire des
signalements soit en tant que présent
d'ailleurs soit tout au long de votre
présence dans le monde du patinage
artistique en tout cas des sports de
glace j'ai eu deux sportifs de niveau
enfin j'ai eu une sportif de niveau qui
m'a contacté directement à titre
personnel pour me m'informer
h les violences n'avaient pas eu lieu
dans le cadre de sa pratique sportive
mais je l'ai quand même dirigé donc à
titre personnel via l'association
colosse au pied
d'argile et la deuxè personne ça n'a pas
été la victime directement mais ça a été
un proche très proche la maman et
c'était ça mettait en cause un
entraîneur enfin plus spécifiquement une
entraîneuse qui était déjà sous-arrêté
euh
préfectoral mais dans ce cadeau-là vous
avez quand même signaler les faits même
s'il y avait une procédure qui était
déjà en cours non non parce que déjà la
procédure donc est en cours donc sur le
2è cas et c'était quelqu'un c'est un
entraîneur qui était à l'étranger on ne
savait même pas dans quel pays et je
vous dis elle était déjà sous euh sous
arrêté
préfectoral et la première personne dont
je vous parle euh je considère qu'elle
m'a appelé à titre personnel et c'est ça
n'est pas à moi de prendre les décisions
sur les suites qu'elle veut donner je
l'ai orienté vers la l'association et je
sais qu'il y a eu un peut-être déjà
encore actuellement un long suivi avec
cette
association pour vous Madame
Nouri pardon euh donc moi concernant les
les référents intégrité oui il y a déjà
eu des des des des finalement auprès de
signal
sport dès que ça rentre dans leur
prérogative évidemment autrement c'est
systématiquement redirigé sur le le le
comité éthique he puisqueil y a des
règles bien particulières pour les
orientations sinon effectivement le
comité éthique peut saisir directement
et d'ailleurs dans les améliorations que
je tenais également à apporter donc dans
le futur c'est de pouvoir mettre en
place cette mesure conservatoire
d'urgence mais vraiment d'urgence parce
que c'est vrai que aujourd'hui seul la
commission disciplinaire peut la mettre
en place il y a donc un délai entre 8 et
10 semaines si ma mémoire est bonne
concernant le le délai pour statuer et
évidemment lorsque c'est vraiment urgent
j'ai envie de dire que c'est toujours
trop long donc dans cette réforme des
des textes nous avons proposé
élaborer l'hypothèse et la
possibilité de considérer trois
personnes c'est-à-dire le président de
la fédération le président du Conseil
fédéral et un autre élu donc trois
personnes on a pensé que c'était le bon
équilibre pour pouvoir suite à un vote
mettre en toute urgence une mesure
conservatoire les textes ont été
proposés évidemment au ministère et ont
été validés donc j'ai bon espoir que
tout cela passe au
vote le 25 novembre prochain normalement
alors j'entends mais ma question en fait
se référait plutôt à vous à titre
personnel En tant que présid ésidente ou
ou d'ailleurs en tant que personne qui a
été au contact de personnes dans le
sport de glace est-ce que vous avez déjà
eu à faire ou été informé de fait qui
aurait nécessité soit un signalement
soit un déclenchement d'article 40 non
moi à titre personnel je n'ai pas été
informé de de de fait déclenchant un
article 40 ou tout autre
signalement pourriez-vous nous expliquer
comment sont menées les enquêtes du
comité d'éthique et la référente
intégrité chargé d'enquêter quand les
violences sont
signalées
euh moi je peux vous dire ce qu'il en
était entre 2020 et 2022 la référente
intégrité donc avait euh le premier
témoignage donc deux témoins ou deux
victimes faisait un petit peu d'ordre
c'est-à-dire qu'elle rappelait elle
creusait elle voilà elle avait euh toute
une liste de questions auquell elle
devait apporter des réponses afin de
constituer un dossier qu'elle faisait
passer au comité éthique le comité
éthique étudier donc le dossier et en
fonction de la gravité ou de l'urgence
saisissez la commission disciplinaire
euh
ou bien euh ou bien proposer une
médiation ou poursuiver
l'enquête voilà madame Nouri
oui donc le le process est toujours un
petit peu le le même hein donc avec
évidemment la la bonne orientation
lorsqu'il s'agit d'éthique c'est le
comité éthique lorsqu'il s'agit de
violence c'est signal sport euh et c'est
vrai que la première intention j'ai
envie de dire
aujourd'hui c'est d'aller vers nos
référents intégrité qui pour le coup je
peux vous le confirmer sont très
réactifs et s'assure vraiment de la
bonne écoute ils prennent attache
directement auprès des personnes ou des
structures et n'hésite pas à orienter
les victimes
ou les les les gens concernés vers les
d'autres structures pour un
accompagnement psychologique ou autrees
et je pense notamment aux associations
qui sont en place colosse ou la voix de
Sara qui a aussi été sollicité à
plusieurs reprises et c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que j'avais envie de vraiment
compléter ce ce panel d'association qui
pouvait écouter répondre et faire aussi
cette
prévention parce que c'était nécessaire
d'avoir un bon suivi et nous sommes
vraiment soucieux de l'accompagnement et
du de de de de comment dire la la la
possibilité de se rétablir pour nos
sportifs donc dans les deux cas que ce
soit entre enfin s votre présidence à
Madame péchla ou madame
Nouri il y a une enquête donc qui est
mise en route on entend la victime on
entend la personne mise en cause c'est
comme ça que ça se
passe la victime si elle est mineure si
elle est très jeune c'est plutôt les
parents généralement la référente
intégré elle appelle pas le prédateur
potentiel ça c'est plutôt comité éthique
qui de son charger et ensuite lorsque la
saisine de la commission disciplinaire
se fait on nomme un chargé d'instruction
qui lui va être amené à a étauer le
dossier donc des deux parties mais je
sais pas si je l'ai déjà dit tout à
l'heure mais c'est très compliqué
d'aller recueillir des des des
informations et par exemple on a eu un
dossier qui mettait en cause un un cadre
technique de la Fédération la drages
donc était informé et mené son enquête
la drages attendait nos conclusion de la
commission disciplinaire alors que nous
nous
attendions les conclusions de la dragess
parce que eux avaient les moyens de de
recueillir plus d'éléments et donc on
est dans un espèce de de système où
où où on nous demande de prendre des des
des décisions sur des éléments qu'on
arrive pas vraiment à recueillir
puisquon n' pas l'autorité pour et donc
moi personnellement je me suis senti
extrêmement démunie comment ça s'est
terminé du coup cette affaire avec enfin
du coup qui a pris la décision en
premier moi je leur ai dit à drag c'est
vous qui êtes compétent en tant qu'organ
déconcentré du Ministère pour aller
chercher les informations donc non ne
nous attendeit pas je leur ais rappelé
le sens de de cette enquête et quand je
suis partie euh il me semble que ça
devait être encore en appel ou que la
commission disciplinaire n'avait pas
encore statué j'ai un doute je sais plus
madame Nouri alors moi j'ai envie de
dire que aujourd'hui on est peut-être un
petit peu plus incisif entre guillemets
c'est que nos référents intégrité
appellent les deux partiesin que ce soit
victime ou prédateur euh ils évaluent et
saisissent si nécessaire ou orientent
toujours dans dans cette bienveillance
et euh je voulais ajouter aussi que au
niveau de de osse au pied d'argile
notamment les mineurs peuvent
parfaitement s'exprimer sous autorité
des des des parents sous contrôle des
parents mais les mineurs peuvent aussi
être
entendu par des personnes qui sont
formées à recueillir ces témoignages une
référente intégrité ne l'est pas
forcément en tout cas celle qui était à
la Fédération entre 2020 et 2022 ne
l'était pas et donc ça n'était pas
préférable et donc est-ce que la
référente maintenant est formée au
recueil des paroles des victimes mineurs
j'entends exact exactement alors ça
excusez-moi parce que c'est peut-être
une nouveauté que que que j'ai oublié
d'exposer c'est que aujourd'hui nos
référents intégrité sont formmer suivre
des des formations auprès d'organismes
habilités pour notamment être en
capacité de de recueillir ces paroles et
quand bien même nous n'aurions pas cette
compétence évidemment nous orientons le
plus rapidement possible encore une fois
pour porter aide et peut-être même
secours à à nos licenciés ou victime
alors à quelle fréquence est-ce que vous
contrôlez l'honorabilité de vos
entraîneurs et lorsqu'il y a une
incompatibilité qui est mise en lumière
par le contrôle euh qu'est-ce qui se
passe est-ce que vous vous arrivez à
vous assurer que la Fédération met
systéement systématiquement fin au
recrutement comment ça se
passe le contrôle de neurabilité des
entraîneurs elle se fait à chaque fois
que on a le renouvellement de la carte
professionnelle voilà et sur le
recrutement des entraîneurs si vous
parlez de ceux qui sont engagés par les
clubs c'est donc un problème qui
concerne un problème c'est donc un sujet
qui concerne le club et la fédération ne
peut pas intervenir dans ce recrutement
sauf si bien sûr il y a un arrêté
préfectoral si on a des éléments
probants madame Nour oui je vous
remercie donc alors moi ma réponse elle
est très claire c'est que le contrôle
d'onnerabilité est refait et renouvelé à
chaque renouvellement de licence euh les
délais de renouvellement de carte pro
sont bien trop
longs donc la licence c'est la licence
c'est à chaque saison
et évidemment je pense que dans les
améliorations à apporter c'est justement
d'avoir peut-être une fréquence un petit
peu plus intéressante et pour aller
encore plus loin j'imagine même d'avoir
PE peut-être aussi des fichiers croisés
qui pourrai être intéressant avec
l'international alors sur ce contrôle
d'honorabilité lorsqu'il y a des donc
des des mises en lumière
d'incompatibilité qu'est-ce qui se passe
au niveau de la Fédération donc
j'entends sur quand c'est d'un club mais
au niveau de la
FD juste pour dire qu'on a pas besoin
d'avoir une licance pour avoir une carte
professionnelle donc il y a des
éducateurs qui ont une carte
professionnelle sans avoir de licence
donc dans le pire des cas évidemment
c'est la carte professionnelle
voilà alors aujourd'hui encore dans les
nouveautés hein nous avons mis en place
en vue de de de ce qu'on avait appelé au
tout départ la maison des entraîneurs
mais qui va s'appeler une commission
pour être plus en adéquation avec les
commissions qui existe déjà et je pense
à la CFO la commission fédérale donc des
officiels d'arbitrage euh nous avons mis
une licence entraîneur donc aujourd'hui
il est obligatoire d'avoir une licence
lorsqu'on est entraîneur évidemment on
est entraîneur lorsqu'on a une carte pro
donc soumis au contrôle d'honorabilité
et je tiens aussi à ajouter que est en
place le code de bonne conduite pour les
entraîneurs et c'est d'ailleurs un code
que j'aimerais avec mes équipes mettre
en place également au niveau des
licenciers donc je répète ma question
lorsqu'il lorsqu'il y a un contrôle
d'honorabilité qui est fait et là on
parle pas que des entraîneurs on parle
des ça peut être des bénévoles ceux qui
sont ceux qui sont autour de de de ces
athlètes de ces sportifs d'ailleurs
parce que ça peut aussi être du loisir
quand il y a une incompatibilité qui est
signalé au moment du contrôle
d'honorabilité quelle procédure est mise
en
place alors j'ajoute juste une petite
précision he c'est que les bénévoles
donc au contact de nos licenciés sont
également soumis au contrôle
d'honorabilité en tout cas aujourd'hui
h évidemment lorsqueil y a un souci euh
j'ai envie de dire qu'il y a une
blacklist et là il faut absolument
bloquer les choses alors est-ce que
c'est tous les bénévoles qui sont soumis
au contrôle
d'onorabilité alors nous notre moyen de
contrôle ce sont notamment les bénévoles
qui sont soumis à la licence
encadrant donc là effectivement il y a
obligation d'avoir ce contrôle
d'honorabilité si sinon c'est vrai que
la définition du mote bénévole elle est
très très vaste on essaie vraiment de de
de de balayer d'avoir un maximum de gens
qui rentrent dans le système pour
pouvoir sécuriser au maximum nos
structures voilà maintenant alors juste
une
précision donc les encadrants ont un
contrôle d'honorabilité vous indiquez a
une black list qui est mise en place
lorsque il y a une une incompatibilité
disent il faut s tenir mais en fait
c'est vous qui prenez la décision de
vous tenir ou pas donc quels sont les
outils dont vous vous dotez pour
justement faire en sorte que tout cela
soit
respecté on ne peut pas lister les gens
comme ça donc on s'est posé la question
quand on a mis en place tout tout le
tout le programme informatique pour
contrôler la nabilité des bénévoles et
donc la seule chose qu'on pouvait faire
c'était faire une blacklist à la main ou
en en fichier excel qu'on puisse mettre
dans dans le serveur fédéral mais ça
peut pas sonner directement sur sur
votre module c'est interdit par la loi
on ne peut pas ficher les gens comme ça
voilà donc c'est à chaque fois aux
équipes au sein de la fédération de
s'assurer régulièrement mécaniquement
que voilà les 10 12 noms qui sont
blacklistés ne font pas partie des
licenciés on ne peut pas interdire
automatiquement la prise de licence
c'est dans le code déontologique de la
prise de lance alors ça j'entends mais
alors je suis un peu surprise alors
c'est nous qui comprenons pas le
contrôle d'honorabilité ou alors il y a
quelque chose qui donc contrôle
deorabilité est effectué il y a une
incompatibilité qui vous
c'est signalé c'est voilà vous avez donc
voilà
euh vous transmettez pas alors est-ce
que c'est transmis au club est-ce que
c'est je je je comprends pas ou alors
vous ou alors vous n'êtes pas informé
que c'est que c'est qu'il y a un
problème sur la l'honorabilité de cette
personne enfin pour moi normalement vous
êtes censé être informé mais bon moi je
vais être très CLA la seule fois où ça
s'est posé c'est par rapport aux arrêtés
préfectoraux où on savait qu' il avait
des entraîneurs qui n'avaient pas la
possibilité d'entraîner et donc c'est là
où on a mis en place la blacklist
c'était sur quelque sur un temps bien
défini 6 mois 9 mois 1 an pas beaucoup
plus et donc à ce moment-là il a juste
fallu vérifier s'ils étaient dans le
fichier ou non s'il s'ils étaient
toujours sur le terrain et donc
j'envoyais des mails par qu'en plus tout
doit être confidentiel donc au président
club pour leur dire sans leur donner les
détails que telle personne faisait
l'objet d'un arrêté préfectoral et que
si jamais
ils étaient vus dans l'enceinte de
patinoir qui n'hésitait pas à remonter
vers nous c'est la seule chose qu'on a
pu faire alors je vais vous demandais de
préciser
euh parce qu'il me semble alors c'est
très compliqué parce qu'on a autant de
versions de contrôle d'honorabilité que
de fédérations que nous avons reçu ici
donc c'est très intéressant de pouvoir
comparer parce que chaque fédération met
en place son contrôle d'honorabilité
mais normalement c'est censé être enfin
pour moi c'est sensé être quelque chose
de centralisé et donc tout le monde doit
rentrer les mêmes informations dans dans
un tableau Excel donc les mêmes données
qui remontent qui sont croisé avec un
fichier qui redescendent donc les clubs
font les contrôles d'honorabilité
ensuite ils sont
informés normalement quand il y a enfin
nous nous a dit ça fait il y a certains
clubs qui nous ont dit c'est c'est rouge
c'est c'est signéal et ce enfin voilà je
vous dis autant de versions que de que
de club et et de fédération et donc dans
ce cas-là soit en fait il y a que deux
options soit vous êtes informé qu'il y a
un problème même avec le contrôle
d'honorabilité et dans ce cas-là
qu'est-ce qui se passe soit vous n'avez
pas l'information et c'est là où ça me
semble tout ça me semble bien compliqué
de se dire qu'on fait un contrôle
d'honorabilité pour ne pas avoir
l'information derrière moi entre 2020
2029 c'était le tout début du contrôle
d'honorabilité on l'a mis en place et je
n'ai jamais eu
d'alerte remontante à la Fédération
c'était l'inverse
ok alors moi ce que je peux vous dire
c'est qu'on a auditionné il faudrait que
je retrouve mes notes la Fédération de
football athan et eux ils ont fait des
contrôles d'honorabilité et ils ont eu
un retour sur par exemple 21 personnes
qui ou c'était pas possible en fait il y
avait un un enfin voilà le contrôle
monorabilité passait pas donc c'est ça
que j'arrive pas à comprendre c'est
pourquoi dans certains cas vous avez des
retours alors peut-être ça voudrait dire
qu'au niveau de la Fédération des sports
de glace il n'y a aucun problème sur les
contrôles d'honorabilité oui ça passe
pas parce qu'il y a des problèmes donc
quand on remplit le le logiciel ça on
l'a eu on a un référence enfin on avait
non ça c'est encore autre chose
ok parce que là on avait un référence
digital donc effectivement ça remonter
il fallait que manuellement il vérifie
les documents qui avaient été
nécessaires à cette prise de
licence des des des noms de famille par
exemple quand on met pas son nom quand
on mettait son nom marital et pas son
nom de jeune fille bah ça bloquait donc
il y en a eu plein des dossiers qui ont
bloqué mais rien pour nous alerter sur
l'extrait de casier je crois que c'est
le B2 si je me souviens bien voilà rien
qui concernait des des des faits de
violence et je crois qu'il y a surtout
l'accès au fichier enfin la comparaison
avec le fichier figes donc parce que
c'est surtout ça qui euh enfin Madame
Nouri peut-être sur ce contrôle
d'honorabilité comment ça se passe ben
écoutez concernant le le contrôle
d'honorabilité effectivement on peut
avoir des
retours qui sont euh euh comment dire à
à à considérer euh euh moi je vous avoue
que dans ces cas-là je vais assez
rapidement vers le ministère donc vous
avez déjà eu au moment des contrôles
d'honorabilité vous avez déjà eu des des
des signalements enfin des des comment
comment on écrit ça des incompatibilités
mises en lumière par le contrôle
d'honorabilité ça vous est déjà arrivé
alors là sur ces moislà je vous avoue
que j'en ai pas eu donc c'est un petit
peu
l'inconnu
d'accord
je crois que c'est une nouvelle version
du contrôle d'honorabilité mais ce n'est
pas grave
[Musique]
euh
donc aujourd'hui si vous faites les
contrôles d'honorabilité et que vous
avez pas eu de retour
visiblement quel est le dispositif pour
enfin quels sont les moyens finalement
pour contrôler et faire en sorte qu'il
n'y ait pas de de prédateur ou de
personne qui a changé de club à
plusieurs reprises par exemple et qui
est mise en cause dans peut-être
certains clubs ou comment ça enfin c'est
quel est votre levier finalement pour
agir sur
cela bah écoutez
euh pour l'instant on essaie dans si si
quand quand ça se présente si ça se
présente de croiser nos nos dossiers et
effectivement euh nous avons le le
réflexe d'aller vers signal sport et et
de de de de signaler éventuellement des
des des soucis mais autrement je n'ai
pas d'autres d'autres leviers
actuellement mais on est d'accord que
signal sport c'est uniquement pour
signaler des des faits de violence donc
là on parle juste de la question du
contrôle d'honorabilité donc vous vous
tournez vers signal sport aussi sur la
question des des bénévoles ou euh je
comprends
pas alors c'est vrai que concernant des
des questions plus classiques si je puis
dire depuis mon arrivée j'ai mis aussi à
disposition des clubs le service
juridique de la Fédération donc j'ai un
avocat qui est conventionné et qui
répond et qui permet d'avoir une
assistance à l'ensemble de nos clubs
gratuitement donc ça c'est le conseil
juridique alors Mo là je ne parle pas du
conseil juridique je ne parle pas des
signalements sur les VSS sous
discrimination ou violence je parle
vraiment du contrôle d'honorabilité donc
pour moi c'est pas signal sport donc
voilà donc comment se passe le contrôle
d'honorabilité dans les clubs
aujourd'hui et au sein de la Fédération
des sports de
glace alors je je vous avoue que là j'ai
j'ai une petite carence dans dans ma
réponse et c'est je regrette pleinement
de de pas pouvoir avoir eu madame
Stéphanie Daval à mes côté qui s'occupe
qui s'occupait justement puisque
initialement elle était présidente du
comité éthique et qui s'occupait de ces
questions là voilà mais pour autant je
me tiens à disposition de de précision
parce que je vois bien qu'il y a un flou
et qu'on a besoin d'avoir des réponses
vraiment vraiment concrète bah
c'est-à-dire que c'est d'autant plus
important que le contrôle d'honorabilité
euh enfin c'est quand même quelque chose
qui est essentiel pour contrôler
justement les bénévoles en tout cas ceux
qui sont encadrant au sein euh de de vos
clubs et et donc de la fédération et moi
ça me semble enfin voilà que vous ne
connaissiez pas la procédure dans son
dans son intégralité je peux l'entendre
mais au moins euh les tenants et les
aboutissants c'est-à-dire comment on le
fait qui le fait où ça va et si vous
avez un
retour pardon donc oui j'ai j'ai quand
même et malgré tout un référent euh qui
s'occupe de de de ces contrôle
d'honorabilité hein donc il remplit
pleinement ses fonctions et
effectivement des dès qu'il y a une
alerte il nous le ferit mais aujourd'hui
heureusement nous n'avons pas d'alerte
oui mais en fait comment enfin puisque
vous ne connaissez pas visiblement le
fonctionnement du contrôle
d'honorabilité comment vous pouvez vous
assurer enfin comment vous vous assurez
d'ailleurs que ces contrôles sont
effectués au sein de de vos clubs
ou ou la
fédération mais justement j'ai une
personne qui est en CH je je de ça et
qui qui
contrôle les les les process et surtout
qu'il n'y ait pas de retour négatif ou
de problèmes particulierers avec un de
nos
licenciers et du coup parce que celle-ci
elle est publique parce qu'on n'a pas eu
enfin vous n'avez pas répondu là-dessus
comment est-ce que vous traitez
aujourd'hui l'affaire Brian
Jubert
donc euh donc aujourd'hui
l'affaire en cours est traitée par la
commission disciplinaire donc il y a
deux dossiers qui sont actuellement et
qui vont être statués d'ici peu sur le
mois de
novembre de ce que j'ai compris parce
que vous avez bien entendu que nous
avons pas forcément l'ensemble
descinalement il y a un certain nombre
qui est arrivé effectivement à la
Fédération de ce que j'ai compris
d'autres sont partis justement sur
signal sport ou voir en en en préfecture
voilà mais ça encore une fois je ne suis
pas dans la boucle je ne peux parler que
de ce qui arrive à la Fédération alors
est-ce que vous vous êtes assuré alors
il y a plusieurs questions un est-ce que
avant que ça ne soit connu dans les
médias est-ce que vous étiez informé euh
de cette affaire en tout cas de de ces
accusations que ce soit vous ou
d'ailleurs au niveau du club est-ce que
quelqu'un était au courant avant que ça
sorte dans la presse et deuxième
question est-ce que vous vous êtes
assuré qu'il y a eu des signalements et
que le club a correctement traité cette
affaire alors moi j'ai eu connaissance
encore une fois par le rapport de du
comité éthique puisque c'est le comité
éthique qui a eu des signalement à
quelle
date alors à quelle
date
j'ai pas la date exact en tête j'aurais
dit mois de
mai donc c'est le comité éthique qui a
récupéré les les signalements et moi le
rapport je l'ai eu avant l'assemblée
général et donc il y a des personnes qui
ont témoigné auprès du comité
éthique qui on qui l'ont saisi qui ont
témoigné comment en fait comment vous
avez l'information comment travaille le
comité éthique alors il y a un
rapporteur donc moi c'est par le
rapporteur je c'est qui attend de de de
signalements qui ont été
déposés c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui l'affire éant en cours et
encore une fois je ne suis pas dans ces
finalement je ne les lis pas donc je
peux pas vous apporter de de précision
d'autant que vous comprenez bien que
c'est placé sous la confidentialité
alors là c'est pas une là on vous
demande pas du tout de rentrer dans le
détail de l'affaire de toute manière
elle est connue au niveau médiatique ce
qu'on essaie de comprendre c'est comment
fonctionne le le les le process de
transmission d'information de
signalement donc là vous nous dites il y
a eu visiblement des signalements donc
ça atéré au comité d'éthique alors de
mémoire il y a eu un signalement qui a
dû arriver sur un de nos référents
intégrité il y a eu deux autres
signalement d'arrivver au niveau du
comité éthique et moi je n'ai eu que les
rapports et au moment où ces
signalements arrivent au niveau du
référent intégré ité du comité d'éthique
qu'est-ce qui se passe est-ce queil y a
un signalement qui est déposé sur signal
sport est-ce qu'il y a une il y a une il
y a un article 40 qui est déclenché
qu'est-ce qui se passe alors si
effectivement ça rentre dans les
prérogatives de signalp c'est
systématiquement déposé au près de sinal
sport concernant le comité éthique via
le rapporteur et également pour le
référent
intégrité alors là je reprends je
reprends ce qu'il y avait dans le dans
dans la presse il est soupçonné d'avoir
entretenu une liaison avec une patineuse
mineure donc ça rentre totalement dans
les prérogatives de signal sport alors
je tiens juste à préciser que ce ne sont
pas mes propos et ce n'est je je là je
je vous lis un article en fait c'est
c'est ça c'était dans voilà ce sont pas
vos propos ce n'est pas mes paroles
puisque j'ai bien en tête cet article je
me suis bien gardé de faire ce genre de
de déclaration cette déclaration ne
vient pas de moi et euh si je ne me
trompe pas cet article qui est du
nouvelops et le fruit de d'enquête de la
journaliste auprès de public mais je
n'ai jamais tenu de tels propos alors
moi je ne dis pas que vous avez alors je
ne dis pas que c'est vous qui avez tenu
ces propos je dis juste que vu la
gravité des faits qui sont reproché et
qu'on parle quand même de rapport sexuel
avec une mineure ça fait partie des
prérogatives de la cellule signal sport
donc ma question c'est est-ce qu'au
moment où il y a le signalement qui est
effectué est-ce que le club en question
ou la personne la référente intégrité a
fait un signalement à Signal sport oui
il y a eu un signalement à Signal sport
il y a eu un article 40 également
merci voyez on y
arrive et peut-être dernière question
parce que vous n'avez pas répondu
euh sur le la notion d'omertin
institutionnalisé vraiment je vous je
vais vous demander de préciser ce que
vous Entz entendez par
là B écoutez dans dans les grandes
lignes c'est vrai que ça a été un petit
peu dans le le mot institutionnalisé
plus dans le
sens dans le mot habituel c'est-à-dire
qu'effectivement même lorsque des choses
sont signalées même des choses graves
peut-être peut-être qu'on se disait ça
n'est pas si grave que ça donc on a
préféré se taire et aujourd'hui c'est
juste intolérable et
insupportable
euh je crois que je n'ai plus d'autres
questions donc je vais vous remercier
toutes les deux pour nous avoir accordé
du temps pour cette
audition merci à vous et voilà tout cela
va nous permettre de continuer à
alimenter les travaux de cette
commission d'enquête dont on rendra un
rapport au mois de
décembre excusez-moi est-ce que je peux
juste rajouter une toute petite chose
parce que ça me tient à cœur c'est vrai
que j'ai lu ma partie de de rapport de
l'Inspection générale mais j'ai aussi
retenu une phrase qui a été notée noir
sur blanc qui disait qu'aujourd'hui les
inspecteurs qui ont été à enquêter à la
Fédération pendant plus de 10 mois
étaient prê à faire confiance à cette
nouvelle gouvernance et
euh de ce
fait remarquer un réel changement et je
tiens vraiment à à à le puisque c'est
c'est c'est ma volonté c'est vraiment ce
travail encore une fois en unité en
équipe aujourd'hui nous sommes ce noyau
dur qui avançons et qui n'est affranchi
de strictement
personne merci
beaucoup j'entends parfaitement et et
encore heureux que sa ici on traite des
dysfonctionnements dans le mouvement
sportif heureusement qu'il y a des
choses qui se passent bien et et que et
même si on en voit pas beaucoup ici à
vrai dire mais l'objectif est bien
justement de faire des propositions très
concrètes pour améliorer le
fonctionnement et peut-être aussi pour
clarifier parce que on sent bien la
complexité dans laquelle on est
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs le fait qu'il y
ait différentes version du contrôle
d'honorabilité des process des parfois
des plateformes de signalement internes
au fédérations parfois signal sport il y
a pas d'homogénéité donc ça prouve bien
aussi la difficulté peut-être pour des
présidents de fédérations qui sont pas
forcément toujours formé d'ailleurs à
toutes ces questionsl de pouvoir
travailler dans de bonnes conditions
voilà l'objectif proposer clarifier et
faire en sorte tout cela bien évidemment
dans le but de permettre au aux jeunes
et moins jeune d'ailleurs de pratiquer
une activité physique en étant protégé
dans le cadre de leur activité je vois
que vous avez un Moot à dire madame
péchla je vous laisse la parole oui
parce que l'éthique c'est pas seulement
la lutte contre les violence c'est aussi
s'assurer que les bonnes personnes sont
au bon endroit drit et bien outillé et
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
il y a il y a cette volonté de
travailler sur un rapport d'étonnement
sur tous les dysfonctionnements fédéraux
je parle de gouvernance je je vous le
dis pas pour qu'on prong forcément
l'entretien là mais pour que vous le
gardiez en tête
absolument la nécessité de s'assurer la
compétence ou l'expérience des personnes
qui sont amenées à être à la gouvernance
des fédération et je parle des trois
postes clés président trésorier et
secrétaire général voilà souvent on nous
demande d'avoir 2 ans de licence pour
moi c'est pas suffisant faut avoir une
connaissance du terrain déjà avant d'y
arriver et ensuite d'avoir une formation
aussi pour nous donner les moyens de
pouvoir prendre notre mission le plus
rapidement possible le fonctionnement
avec les instances aussi
extrafédéral sportive évidemment et puis
peut-être aussi un éclairage euh un peu
plus poussé sur tout le volet
événementiel notamment les les
subventions accordées sur les grands
événements organisés donc sur not notre
territoire le contrôle de la billetterie
voilà il y a plein de petites choses
donc je peux pas forcément vous faire
toute la liste peut-être que vous n'êtes
pas là pour ça mais je voulais vous le
dire je voulais absolument que vous le
gardiez en tête il y a besoin de
d'accompagner d'outiller de
former les personnes qui sont amenées à
être les garants du monde sportif
d'aujourd'hui de demain qui gère des
millions qui engagent l'État dans leur
sélection
internationale voilà ça me semble
important de de le
souligner merci beaucoup à à toutes les
deux alors peut-être ce qu'on ce que je
peux aussi vous dire c'est que vous
pouvez nous envoyer donc vous pouvez
déjà reprendre la tâche avec la
commission d'enquête nous envoyer des
propositions donc ce que vous venez
d'indiquer notamment ça peut être
intéressant parce que nous aussi on
travaille voilà sur cet aspect aussi de
simplification y compris du point de vue
des différents organismes qui composent
aujourd'hui le monde du sport donc
n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer vos propos
et tous les documents que vous estimez
nécessaires pour pouvoir peut-être
éclairer aussi peut-être par rapport aux
imprécisions qui ont été dans le cadre
de cette commission pour PIR nous donner
plus d'éléments précis sur ce que vous
avez pu nous dire voilà merci à vous
deux merci bonne
soirée